Do Do,
do,
do
[inaudible] could see your breath to see your brother.
How are you?
Good man.
Um,
the charcoal,
it's you.
That's me.
I sent Santinello picture.
I'll send it to you Jamie.
You've seen it so fucking funny.
I want residuals on that shit.
What is it called?
Lucky Dev or bro,
it you,
it's,
that's a cue with a steak.
Devil something.
I put it up online.
I was like,
this is so fucking funny.
This is me with my own charcoal company called,
uh,
if you're in the market for some charcoal man.
Oh,
jealous devil.
That's what it is.
That's so big.
That veered fucking steak down there with a,
with a knife.
Jealous Devil Barbecue is the only truly manly way of cooking.
Like nobody brags about having a Baker's hat on.
Yeah,
there,
there is.
There it is.
All natural hardwood,
hardwood,
charcoal.
There is nothing you can do.
The uh,
do you smoke?
You smoke or just just use a trigger.
You know what that is not like a pellet grill.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right?
Yeah.
Shit,
man,
they're so easy.
And did you finish in a skillet or no?
Yeah.
That's the way to go.
Right,
baby with beef tallow.
Ooh,
what does that,
and you know what else I use?
Huh?
Minced garlic and rosemary.
I put rosemary in the,
in the cast iron skillet with the beef tallow.
It's like an extra,
an extra,
I learned that in a tie in restaurant.
I was going to say,
are you guys doing?
And he's like,
we use a rosemary,
rosemary,
Rosemary.
It's a wonderful Maria.
Bye.
If I go to an Italian restaurant.
That dude talks like that.
I am excited.
I'm stoked.
I'm more pumped.
Yeah.
It's just a regular person.
Even if they're nice,
I'm disappointed.
Yeah.
It's like the nicest waiter ever.
I'm like,
dude,
you seem like a great guy,
but damn,
I wish you were from Italy and Freddy Cine Alfredo.
You're like,
Hey,
you ready from Italy back there,
man.
You Malibu.
Fuck,
that's a weird one.
Right?
It's like Italian restaurants particularly like I go to a Greek restaurant.
I would hope that guy would not have an accent.
I don't,
yeah,
we don't need them to,
I wouldn't care if he could race as long as I can understand them.
That's great.
But I don't require it,
but I required at an Italian restaurant.
Yeah.
Cause it's just,
there's something about it that's different.
And then everywhere else Mexican,
you know what I mean?
Everything else was Mexicans,
Chinese chained by Mexicans,
Chinese maybe by Mexican,
Mexican or Mexican people in making Chinese food.
It's always one of those weird things you're like,
Huh,
okay.
Is this gonna it's just gonna measure up though.
Like at those,
um,
you know those,
those chain places,
those Chandon which called pf Chang's,
not pf Changs is not as much.
That's like a restaurant.
You order it,
it's pf Changs is pretty fucking good.
But that's all Mexicans cooking that shit.
There's no like Chinese guy greets you.
They're talking time for a second.
Have you ever been to a Buka to Beto?
Like,
oh,
am I going to college?
That was my job as and pookah Bebo if you want like straight up filling old
school Italian food,
it's so much,
Bro.
They will hook you up.
They try to fucking kill you.
Wait a minute.
Book booking tobacco is the Chinese food of Italian places.
Do you know what I mean?
Like how Chinese place to give you way too much food but eat buffet 50 pounds a
fucking pasta when you're gonna book book book in a bubble,
they bring that aluminum 10 out with the Rigatoni and you're like,
who the fuck are you for a full fucking kingdom and your servants?
Listen,
this is silly.
Yeah,
it's absurd.
Turning me into an asshole and that's also Rigatoni like that kind of food.
You keep going,
you can go on even when it hurts,
you don't stop like that carb when that,
when you're hitting like a good linguine with clams like Ah,
why you're eating.
It's so gluttonous.
Chill.
We go,
that has no nutritional value is going into your stomach.
Like,
oh,
it's so good.
You can't wait for more mixed in with some sauce to give the illusion of
healthiness.
Oh,
there's green,
little bit of green on it and you just like when your body is trying to process
it afterwards like,
Oh you feel fucked up sometimes when you eat too much pasta you feel like drunk
actually like stoned or drunk cause I'm broken.
My Body's just like all your resources planning all that shit down.
So fucking gross.
Good.
Everybody remembers from like time we were kids.
Apparently someone told me that you don't get a significant enough amount of
trip to fan from Turkey for it to put you to sleep.
Yeah,
I've heard it's bullshit.
I want to know if that's true though.
That's true.
So I've been told that there is tripped if there's always tripped to fan that's
been in Turkey.
But uh,
the,
the running joke is that after Thanksgiving dinner you pass out,
but it's actually because of all the other shit you're eating.
Fucking mashed potatoes on the carbs.
A fucking Brit.
Hawaiian bread rolls car.
Yeah.
Contrary to popular belief,
eating Turkey isn't the main reason you feel sleepy after Thanksgiving feast.
The oft repeated Turkey myths stems from the fact that Turkey contains an amino
acid trip to fan,
which forms the basis of brain chemicals to make people tired.
But it's not true
but it's not.
I mean it does but it's not the thing that knocks you out.
Being a fat fucking sitting on your couch and drinking 40 beers is what makes
you sleepy.
Yeah,
so it says trip to fan is component of the brain.
Chemical Serotonin would get converted into the well known sleep inducing
hormone,
Melatonin and poultry and many other foods also contain trip to fan.
Chickens got similar amounts.
Yup.
Gram per gram.
Cheddar cheese actually contains more trip to fan than Turkey does
suck on net cheese heads.
Yeah.
Cheese folks.
It's just being a glutten man.
He's just become a fat piece of shit in the hall.
You just feel like you're supposed to keep
eating and eating and eating.
There's an interview with Katt Williams is sitting in the back of a limo.
I talked about this with ms pat or he talked about not eating before shows and I
was like,
he's right.
Like why would I eat before shows and it made me realize,
oh even before shows is a terrible idea because anybody's got to process all
that and you'd come out.
Yeah,
calf
asked.
We don't know.
We never eat before shows and we do shows we never eat before.
Shows after shows is actually when it tastes the fucking best.
I'll have some fruit,
I'll have a little bit of fruit before a show.
I have a little something like a little baby thing.
I don't mind some fruit cause you have some fruit.
It's like you're getting some carbohydrates are getting some sugar,
you're getting some fiber.
It's super easy to digest like melon and a melon.
Your buys just,
you could lift,
you could to eat melon and then do a sick kettlebell workout.
Like it's not going to fuck.
You know like melons,
easy to little baby sugar rush to that probably helps your energy a little bit.
Your body just,
you mash it into mush so quick and it just goes sliding down there.
Your body's like,
oh we got this.
We should do though.
We should do the tired tour where we just eat a huge meal before we get on stage
and see what,
see what comes out of that fucking shit.
Compare Mellon to like a stromboli like one of those ridiculous fucking sausage
and she is with the layers but the bread and the cheese is burnt at top.
You know they burn it on the towel and you,
you take a couple of bites of that and just like aw.
And he just keep going.
But if you looked at like the size of what you would eat in one of those mother
fall design,
the boop boop.
The Bible is to lay layers and layers.
We fucking got it.
That will take you down son.
You ain't doing no fucking crosswords after that.
Cheese,
pasta,
cheese,
cheese.
Sit the fuck down.
This more cheese coming.
You ain't play no puzzles bitch.
That I would run at the brain activity slows down so much more.
Like I wonder what the at the active level of brain activity is when your
stomach,
oh yeah,
you're useless.
I feel like a fucking lose like 80 points of Iq.
You have just get around like someone should come to you and try to get you to
do things.
Yeah.
You'll fucking sign off on stuff.
You'll change your marriage license.
Fucking leave me alone.
Right.
Do I going to write right there?
Get fellas,
you want your wife to sign a prenup?
Go ahead and fat are out on.
Poke it up.
Oh,
Lasagna and then she'll sign whatever the fuck he won't give up.
I don't think I could drink.
Like when I drive home after having a full meal,
I feel more fucked up and like out of it than if I have a couple of drinks.
It will you definitely slower.
Oh yeah.
Your reaction time would be slower if you are full and you were driving.
Just like,
it's just like you're tired when you're full and you don't talk as well.
You articulate things as quickly.
Yeah.
It's like it's gotta be related and I was like,
I was part,
I worked there for four years.
That's why I know so much about it.
But part of the thing you're supposed to sell at the end of the meal is like
lemon,
cello or espresso cause it's supposed to be like a digest.
Now I don't know if that's how your retic yeah,
sales pitch,
but maybe it is something to that where it helps you a little better.
And that's why they all drink Italy.
They all,
they all do it as a end of the meal to clear you out a little bit.
Yeah.
It's going to help you break down some shit and so you can kicks in and the
chair,
the chairs in Italy turn into toilets.
You know that round
in Brazil,
when you go to those two,
Haas Korea's um,
they have this delicious dessert that has a Papaya in it and it's like a Papaya
smoothie.
Tennis.
It's like a blended Papaya drink and a dessert rather.
And they,
they have that specifically because the enzymes and Papaya helped break down the
meat.
Oh,
it does?
Yes.
Wild.
And it's fucking delicious,
dude.
It's a speaking know what's the channel?
What's that chain?
That Brazilian change?
Fogo de Chao.
Chao.
Yeah.
I'll get a child.
That's it right there,
Dude Sun that will fucking rock you at the end of a good meals or booze in
there.
You can get boots.
They have a guy that comes by.
I'm only say no cause I'm not a drunk.
But you I would say port.
Yeah.
That's the first question I ask.
Is there a Bougie?
It's good with booze.
It's good without booze too.
It's just good.
I looked at those wishes.
I went there with that.
A Ufo Guy,
Bob Ozar.
Ozar want there with yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
Sholtz Andrew Schultz wanted me to yeah,
and Jeremy Core Ball.
The guy who made the documentary,
we all sat around talking to them.
That Lazard dude freaked me the fuck out man.
He's a freak out like me want to move.
I,
you know,
I had no indication that he's full of shit.
I mean I was zero bullshit meter.
Here's the thing,
man,
when you've told a story for his many years,
as many times as he did,
it's a,
it's super hard to be consistent if you're just making everything up.
It's super hard to,
to,
to have things that you're saying back then that everybody says don't even
exist.
Right.
Eventually turn out to be true.
It's very difficult to deny that.
Like these are parts of his initial story is initial story had something to do
with this thing called element one 15.
Which uh,
most people,
I mean they didn't even recognize that it actually existed until much later.
Right.
That's a big feature of it.
When did he start talking about it once you're talking about the eighties
seventies eighties right.
A long time ago.
But it's about,
look,
I don't know enough about elements and the table to understand it.
You're talking to a state school kid here.
Double Shit.
Both stupid.
You'd probably more educated than me though.
But at the end of the day,
this guy is obviously smart as fuck.
And he's a scientist that definitely worked at Los Alamos lab.
There's,
yes,
there's a record of him there.
Right?
And they tried to deny that and they tried to erase it.
That alone tells me just the fact that they tried to say that he didn't exist.
He never went.
He never worked at Los Alamos lab.
That's a,
that is freaking huge.
Freaky.
Yeah.
In the 1980s you don't think they can just erase your past,
right?
Right.
You don't think that they could just erase your birth certificate or erase your,
your,
your medical records are ratioed dental records.
They could do whatever they want back then we'll,
we'll tell me you shot that documentary about the three identical strangers.
Did you watch her worried about I didn't see it bro.
I heard,
oh my God.
I mean essentially in so many words I can,
without divulging too much,
three brothers are born,
a triplets are born and they are separated at birth.
Unbeknownst to them,
they grow up completely independently run into each other later in life.
This was in the 70s I think it was seventies and they meet publicly on,
maybe not Donahue,
but one of those fucking big shows,
you know,
like they bring them all together and they ended up finding out later on the
documentary,
spoiler alert that the comp,
there's a company
who is doing this that's doing trial tests on babies that are separated and
putting them with different families to find out if they end up growing up with
similar um,
characteristics,
nature versus nurture,
nature,
nurture,
scientific experiment.
But imagine how sick you have to be.
Fuck to decide to separate kids.
Yep.
And t dude and show up and test their family to find out how their breeding,
these are,
how they're growing these children gross as fuck.
You wash it,
right James.
They'd come test them every week or two and just be like doing checkups and they
didn't,
the parents almost didn't even know.
I don't,
I'm not sure other and seem to be more keen about it.
And the other one's just felt like,
well they were getting money for it.
So they were like,
this is just a part of a program that we're in pro.
How has that much different than aliens abducting people?
And that's what I'm saying.
It's not,
it's not.
That's my point is like if they got away with that
life and and in genetics test pro involved,
mostly they have the data from that to like the nurse or the assistant from the
get the doctor that was doing it says there is data.
She has read it but it has never been released and it should be because they
fucked up on,
oh wait,
you're leaving on an important part.
It's in a library in a,
in like Harvard Law Library in it legally can't be released to the public.
It's something that's,
it's someone's holding onto it and it cannot be released.
They've tried hundreds of times and it's got a 2050 release date or whatever.
Their whole,
they're waiting for these people to die.
So then it'll just go away and no one will think about it anymore.
It's fucking,
dude,
watch it.
It'll fuck you up.
I'm scared.
And then you find out in the documentary,
they're not the only ones.
There's,
they've done this over and over and over and over.
It's,
Fuck Dude,
I'm sitting on a plane watching it and Reptilians yes.
You know,
when you're,
you know,
you're on a plane watches,
I'm so good.
And you look around like the other people,
you're like,
fuck no one's watching it.
But I'm like,
fuck it.
Shit.
It was so trippy,
man.
It's so trippy.
So yes.
Do I think that Lazaro had people trying to x out his,
his PA for sure.
For sure.
And
there's a look,
there's a lot of other stuff that you gotta go,
hmm.
I Dunno.
How do you,
how do you prove that?
How do you explain that?
Well,
I don't know.
Isn't not like anything in our world.
What do you believe in?
The big questions are,
is the education background.
That was a big one.
Um,
what do you mean credibility wise?
No,
whether or not he actually was educated at a certain place.
I'm not,
I can't,
this is a fucked up one,
but I can't say what he told me.
I,
um,
but essentially without saying it,
it had to do with projects he was working on currently,
no,
at the time when he's working in Los Alamos labs,
I can't say anything more than that.
Fuck.
And now the internet exploded.
I don't know if it's true.
Right.
Who Do you know who told them?
I wouldn't say anything.
So I said I wouldn't say anything and I'm not going to say anything,
but whatever he said about all these different things,
only he knows if it's true.
Right.
When you're talking to a guy,
it doesn't seem like a liar.
Seems like he's very intelligent.
I mean when he's talking about all kinds of different things,
very intelligent.
So either he's running the greatest 30 year con of all time,
or maybe this really did happen when you talk to them.
So you're just guessing.
You don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know his life.
I don't know his real life.
Right.
Just gas out.
But he seems like a guy who seen some shit and just didn't know what to do and
told some friends about it and then then went to the news.
And that's what that George Knapp guy who was the investigative journalists that
studied this case over all the years,
like this guy's never wavered.
Like he stuck with the story over and over.
Things have shown to be true that they said were science fiction.
Like the um,
there was this equipment that they had at Los Alamos labs that he talked about
where was this a thing that measured the distance or the sides rather of the
digits in your finger.
And apparently it's like a great,
like your fingers that the inches are specific.
And so like if you put your hand down that thing and then Jamie's hand,
it would give a different measurement.
Like there's different,
each bone is a different length and it's the exact length is of like 1.7,
whatever the fuck it is,
you know,
1.7 inches,
whatever men measurement,
teal tool they use.
It was,
it was calculating the length of your fingers through some kind of buggy system
that he said didn't really work that often.
But people said that science fiction,
it doesn't exist.
And then they finally got photos of these things and people that worked at Los
Alamos labs concluded or are they a conceited that these were real things,
but for a long time they were fighting and Pete,
some people that didn't know were saying he made that stuff up.
It doesn't exist but insurance shut it.
It does exist.
And it did exist right there where he worked.
He even took them on a tour through the labs,
like he knew where everything was.
He used to work there.
So he,
when they went there with the documentary crew with Jeremy Corbell,
they just walked him through.
He showed where he worked,
he walked right in there and they do look mainly the guys running the craziest
con game of all time and he's just a super genius and way smarter than me.
And he tricked me and he thinks it's hilarious or maybe he saw some shit.
What he was explaining that made it more and more interesting was how
compartmentalized it was.
And I about how the problem with being so compartmentalized is that science is,
it's based on free exchange of information.
Right?
Yeah.
You have to have guys who are testing all these different things and working on
them together.
That's the only way he could do so.
Right.
So he's limited to a couple of guys that are working on the propulsion system.
And then there's a couple of other guys that are working on the metallurgy and a
couple other guys that are working on the navigation system.
And they chose him because he was kind of a maniac and he put a fucking jet
engine in the back of a Honda.
And it was on the cover of the Los Alamos newspaper.
And it said in the article about Bob was our,
but this fucking jet powered Honda that he was a scientist at Los Alamos lab,
a physicist.
So this was in the newspaper.
They printed this,
this guy was doing this thing where he said he was living at the time in the
area where Los Angeles was.
And it said in the newspaper that he worked at the lab,
there's a fucking logbook of employees.
It's got his name in it.
From that time a guy had it,
he showed it,
they took photos of it.
They showed it to everybody.
Look,
we have an employee log book like this or the employee directory rather
Robert Lasar right there.
So he worked there.
He really did work.
How could he,
how could all the,
I mean,
how could you fabricate that?
Everybody's scared to talk.
All the people you've worked with are scared to talk.
Why do you think this?
Look at what's happening to him and he looks like a fool that FBI raids his
house.
Everybody calls him crazy.
He didn't want have anything to do with this.
The only reason why he wanted to do my podcast,
he was what he liked.
He wanted one more chance to just get it out in a form where it's just him
talking and he felt like he and I,
we both talked about,
I think me and you talk,
I'll just let you talk.
You tell me what happened and I'll let everybody figure out if it's true.
I don't know.
What do you think?
Honestly,
there was parts of me that said maybe I'm just dumber than this guy,
and he's like really manipulative and maybe he just knows how to tell a story
and steady fucking King Dude.
I know,
but it's a tricky thing,
man.
You can get cocky,
you can get cocky.
I feel like you don't get cocky and think that you know that someone's not full
of Shit.
Yeah.
But I feel like you talk to enough fucking people who are and aren't full of
shit that your meter is higher than most.
I'm also nice,
so when I'm trying to talk to someone,
I want a one things to work out well and giving the benefit of the doubt.
Often I want them to have a good time when we're talking.
I don't want to confront people,
even if I angrily disagree with every fiber in my being,
as I've gotten older and better at it,
better at talking to people,
I avoid that kind of conflict.
I just,
I don't think it's necessary,
but I just don't.
I just think your bullshit meter is keen enough where you don't really like,
I think it's super cocky to say that.
I would like to think it is.
Yeah.
My Ego would like to say like a fuck though,
bro.
Just try to lie.
I've had people lie to me,
dude,
I know NASA brow that eight NASA stuff fit on anything.
There is times when you know someone's full of Shit and there's times where you
think you know someone's full shit and you're wrong.
Then you know,
it's like this whole thing of looking at someone's eye and talking to them.
Sometimes someone will tell you something like,
oh bro,
I didn't even know you called me.
Like you motherfucker fucking see it right in their eyes.
Like you piece of shit.
You didn't see your text demand.
I didn't even see it.
He didn't say,
you fucking Solomon Pitch.
Fuck that shit.
You know?
Who knows?
I don't know.
It freaked me out.
I'm not gonna lie came.
He was like,
fucking,
sometimes you have to do that to people.
What?
Hey Man,
I didn't get your call.
Is it better off to say,
Hey,
I find you a little annoying and very needy and so when I get a phone call from
you off and I cringe,
I do like you and I enjoy our time,
but sometimes I just can't.
Sometimes I can't.
That's probably the most healthy version.
But you can say that.
No you can't.
You have to go like this.
You Go,
I didn't.
You did today.
Oh fuck.
I didn't see ya.
Sorry man.
Yeah,
I didn't see it.
Did you not get my tax?
That's when people that bothered me,
you do you not get my tax.
I always say,
sorry,
I didn't respond to your texts.
I try to say that first,
but let me tell you something as,
as a man,
if I text you and I'll get a text back,
I don't care what that am going to fucking butt hurt,
right?
No,
I just go.
That's lets it.
He saw it.
It is what it is.
We move.
I don't send a text in needing or if I needed a real response from you,
I would call you and go,
Hey,
I need to talk to you about something.
You ever have someone send you a text that's like a little on the needy side and
then they send you one like three minutes later it says hello every day.
Every fucking day.
Jamie.
Everyday to me when you coming over,
when are you coming over and common Jamie,
me alone from our afternoon pump session.
You know,
some people just get real weird with like them sending them messages in a bottle
and then there's this little little message.
Did you get it?
And then the other side of it is Bobby Lee,
who literally never answered the text.
Ever.
Ever,
ever.
I've sent him a thousand texts.
Yeah,
he doesn't answer good for him.
His,
his uh,
green,
you know,
his notification is like 800 fucking little red.
You know,
he never answers,
he doesn't give a shit,
but I kind of,
but everyone who's friends with them knows that's just Bobby.
Yeah.
Joey just calls you.
Yeah,
Joey.
I texted him
a lot more.
I've been calling people a lot more,
more personal.
Well,
it's also like you can't call as many people as you can text,
and I think there's an overload of communication that occurs when you're texting
with like 10 different friends at the same time.
I got dudes sending me videos than kicking pads and people show me,
let me look at this fish.
I caught like,
I'm a fucking get these texts all day from all these crazy interesting people.
Imagine if I got that many phone calls in a day.
It would be insane to turn your phone.
Be like,
Hey,
what's up man?
Hold on.
Someone's calling me.
Hey,
what's up Tom?
Like you would never right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you would never,
if you think about it,
even if you have like three friends and you're texting each other back and forth
throughout today,
make jokes.
Maybe you didn't have like a group chat.
Like a lot of us are in group chats,
talk about Shit and show ridiculous pictures she wanted it would get me kicked
out of the country for sure.
Right.
I mean,
you would never do that.
If it was phone calls,
you'd be like,
you need bitch.
I gotta call you all day.
I'm calling you in the morning and I call you in the afternoon.
Are we fucking like what's happening?
Even if we were,
if you,
if you needed me to call you that many times in a day,
be like,
hey,
like we gotta we gotta be happy to be in alone,
to be happy,
be together.
But also you gotta be able to be alone.
If you need phone calls all day long,
hey,
chill out.
Chill out at Texas.
Good cause you could be in the middle of some shit,
right?
If you're one of them dudes was inclined to change a transmission.
You want to rebuild an old Chrysler or something like that.
You could be under there and then a little text message,
I'll get back to him.
Look,
I figured that out.
That's Mike actually.
Maybe real quick.
Yeah,
we're going to meet a date.
You know,
like it's minimal,
right?
There's metal to,
but isn't that bad
to be talking to people that way?
Isn't it?
Is it bad to be talking to people so much to shit diet?
Yeah.
It's a shitty diet.
Duncan and I were talking about the other day about,
um,
like finding information online.
Just constantly be inundated with stories of horrific things and bad things,
terrible things in ugly things that it's a bad diet.
It's a bad like mine died and I was like,
you're so right that that makes you think you're like immune to that.
That you are who you are and this is just some stuff you're experiencing,
but much like if you eat healthy foods,
your body feels better.
I think if you concentrate on healthy things and interesting things and
fascinating things and not horse shit,
I think you're giving yourself a better mental diet.
Totally.
I think if you consume too much of anything,
it's bad.
Right?
So consuming too much of even two Ku,
too much positive information can be fucking detrimental because you can get
delusional.
Yes.
So you have to have some semblance of a balance of how you ingest that.
The people that only ingest negative delete.
People only eat candy.
If you are grown adults and for like 10 years you only ate candy,
your body would be a mess.
A fucking just barely alive if you just had to live off snickers bars.
How much nutrition isn't a snickers bar?
Like I want to do something with that dude who did the 30 days with a big match
size.
Me Guy.
How about this guy?
Hey Bro,
do this.
Just eating nothing but snacks.
See how long you stay alive there satisfies to a point.
That's why you're hungry.
I guess.
They're delicious.
They're phenomenal.
I love a snickers bar.
They're great to take on hikes too,
by the way.
What really?
Yeah.
A lot of nutrition in their burning sugar man.
Fucking hiking up mountains and ship he beloved snickers bars.
Wow.
But Hey,
I think even the snickers people would tell you don't live off that shit stupid.
You can't live off a steam.
Isn't that interesting?
Like there's a food you eat that you cannot live off of?
Yes.
Because all food at one point you had to eat to live of off of how many days do
you think that you could go with only eating snickers bars and should this be
the sober October challenge?
Yes.
First of all,
yes.
And second of all,
what if we don't know Burger die?
Burt will die,
but I mean that is what it is.
If you only could eat snickers bars and water two weeks,
two weeks,
two weeks without your body malfunctioning,
I think something's going to happen.
Yeah,
imagine I'm dumb.
You'd get,
does it post,
I just found from like two years ago where people ask it,
ask this question.
It was a discussion.
Someone did the math and get the about 12 to get the caloric intake to get that
2000 a day.
12 a day just for 2000 calories.
But how many days could you survive?
I on,
I mean that's up to you.
Well,
Bro List.
Think about that.
12 and snickers bars a day.
Holy Shit.
How long do you think,
okay.
The problem with that is like everyone is not coming from the same starting
point.
Right?
That's the biggest issue.
Don't have to have three twin guys where I separated them,
make them all eat snickers to one of them dies.
You guys need,
you guys need to control.
You guys need some sort of control.
They would be the test.
Just feed them.
Give them $1 million each.
Give him nothing but snickers until someone's on the verge of death until
somebody taps tap out.
Bitch.
How many days you think you could go on?
Only snickers.
I say two weeks is probably the human body will start to shut down.
I wonder,
maybe you could go a long time.
Well let me say this.
You could,
you could fucking find this.
There's a dude that's been eating just pizza for like 25 years.
Breakfast,
lunch and dinner will find that too.
There's a dude that he's just pepperoni pizza.
I respect that and it's like,
fuck it.
My parents told me what to do my whole life and I'm a grown.
He's now bitch.
I picked everyday just crying and eating pizza and there were socks,
Journal.
Let's try to get him to have like a piece of green leafy Greens.
Puked puked on camera.
That was like,
aw,
he couldn't fucking do it.
Fuck in us.
It's Bazell and a nice sauce.
Get the fucking Green Shit at a pizza for 20 years.
Something like that.
Saying,
what was that Jamie?
Was it 25 years?
He says he has one bowl of raisin bran a week.
Shit,
that compacted glue.
That's what pizza is like.
Glue,
mixed blue cheese.
Just chewing down a little bit.
Joe.
That delicious dough.
Holy Shit.
25 years.
She does have diabetes.
Of course he does.
Duh.
Color me surprised.
How the fuck,
sorry buddy for laughing at your diabetes,
but how the not at all.
Not Sorry.
How to fuck this.
Someone eat nothing but that glue for 25 years.
That's the cat.
That's him.
That's good.
Let's say he's 48 guys should be doing youtube videos,
so what do they call?
They call him skinny fat.
There was an article that call them like,
you know,
ski.
No skinny fat,
right?
Yeah.
He looks remarkably good for someone who's only in pizza for 25 years.
It might be something to it,
but they say skinny,
fat,
skinny,
fucking as people look skinny,
fat,
skinny,
fat.
We're like,
the body is,
she doesn't show any signs,
but the insights fucking murdered.
It's it apart.
Yeah.
Well she opens her failing.
Nothing's there.
Yeah.
That's why you can look small,
but you don't have anything.
They're skinny fat people.
Limbs are barely hanging on threads.
It's like certain people,
you know,
certain people like you hug them and you're like,
oh my God,
God,
there's nothing there.
You're so frail.
So it is funny when you,
when you hold,
that's like when I take pictures after shows and say how to people.
Yeah.
You know when you grabbed it and you feel,
and some people you feel in your like,
wow,
that's fucking weird.
It's weird.
You're like a fucking,
just a lump of bone sticks,
sticks covered with Jello.
It's terrible.
Bony lumpy bag.
What's really terrible is when,
I mean,
I'm not saying you have to be a bodybuilder.
Oh,
but you have to fuck.
It's,
she keep your body moving.
And when it's just a laziness thing.
It's a discipline thing and like this idea that some sort of nobility and
humility and not caring about your body.
It's silly.
I'm out of here.
One,
you get one.
It doesn't make you dumber.
If you work out,
stop.
I know the jocks were assholes and people bullied you.
I get it.
Yeah,
but God dammit.
Take care of your fucking meet vehicle.
Just go take care of it.
Care the meat skeleton people.
You're being this way.
You work.
Oh yes.
That too.
I like looking good.
I like it.
It's better to me than not looking good.
I'm sorry.
I'm willing to put in the time,
but you know what the irony is shell because of the hype of,
because of the growth,
growth of MMA.
Cheers.
In my brother because of the growth of MMA,
crossfit,
all of these,
all these new worlds that have kind of emerged socially now that are so much
bigger than they were years ago.
Nerds from that I grew up in the high school or now are into working out.
Yeah.
That's the irony.
That's a big thing.
Once you do too.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like the biggest like insecure people now they found a home in something
that's disciplined.
It's good.
It feels good to move your body.
It feels good.
It feels good to do things.
Whether it's taken a dance class,
I'm not into that,
but taking karate,
I'm not into that shit.
I like Yoga.
I like running or like doing Jujitsu obviously.
I like all kinds of,
all kinds of martial arts and I have this like moving my body man.
I like wandering uphills.
You move your body,
so I think going,
you'll feel better afterwards.
I know you don't want to do it.
I never,
I fucking hardly ever want to do it.
If I may be wanting to want to actually do it five out of 10 times,
but maybe less.
Yeah,
but I do it.
I just do it.
I know what it's like to not want to do it.
I get it.
Shut up.
I just started talking to myself.
I go,
come on Pussy.
What are you talking about?
If I was you,
outside of you knowing what I know,
if I could read my mind,
I'd be like,
come on bitch,
you just being lazy.
Put your fucking shoes on,
get up,
get a sweat going,
and then you're gonna feel pumped.
C'Mon man,
you've done this a million times and then invariably I'll be in the middle of
the workout.
I'm sweating.
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then I get into it.
It's like it just,
you got to push past that creepy resistance that Steven Pressfield wrote about
in the war of art.
It,
it applies not just to art,
not just a writing replies.
It applies to clean your room and applies to saying you're sorry to a friend.
It applies to you taking care of a debt.
All those things you just keep putting off.
It's this weird thing that you have when you see a problem,
you got to fix it,
right?
See the thing you have to do,
go do it when you know something like clean your fucking room.
Right?
That's what Jordan Peterson always says,
clean.
You're clean,
your room and your room and that's,
that really is what he means.
Get your shit in order.
We'll do it and I think,
I think it's also a personality trait though too.
To be fair.
Like I fucking,
I'm someone that has to get it done.
You know when someone goes,
you don't have to do it all at once on the opposite.
I'm like,
yeah,
you do.
Yeah,
you fucking do like my,
she wants new blinds at the house.
What if we just do the living room for now?
I was like,
none of us do get the whole fucking thing done.
What's the difference?
That's a manly thing to say to get it to fuck,
man.
What can we just have this window,
this window?
Just this'll be my shade spot.
A man goes,
hey,
some code a whole fucking pay back the truck up all around.
What can be some no fucking bites?
I want trees around this out.
I want to walk around my cock counts.
You could buy an old tree,
you know that you could buy like I want a tree in my yard,
500 years old.
They'll find you one.
That's dope though.
Nope,
that's cool.
To be like,
place it here.
I got to fucking,
I have 150 plus old oak tree in my backyard.
Here's what's weird shit.
Safe.
You have a piece of land,
right,
and that piece of land is a hundred acres of beautiful piece of land.
You know?
You don't own the animals on that land.
Like if there's wildlife on that land or there's a bunch of deer on that land,
you can't just shoot him.
You have to have tags.
You have to have state allocated tags.
They give out a certain amount based on the deer population using wildlife
biologists and they view it from helicopters and shit.
They,
everyone has different way.
They've trail cameras,
all these different ways.
They determine the numbers.
Then they figured out how many people can hunt,
but you own the trees and that weird and all the trees.
Yeah.
You own everything that they're around.
Don't some gigantic population of of pine trees in the forest,
like you own some giant swath of land that you're logging.
Like those logging companies.
Do they own those tree somehow?
How they don't own the deer.
They don't own the elk alum.
The Eagles,
but they own the fucking trees.
It's weird.
Maybe it's because the trees don't move.
Yeah,
that's exactly what can't movement are easy to just,
I could just take that.
Yes.
Saw that thing.
So they like completely over fish,
you know what I mean?
The virus and then they,
they leave these big cut like these huge cut areas.
Like if you've ever been to the woods and seeing a place that's been logged.
Yep.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
It's wild to see.
Oh that's kind of beautiful.
In a weird way.
I hate to say it,
but it's not,
you're like wow,
that's,
it's mesmerizing.
You know,
it's,
it's a key area for hunting too,
right.
Pick of,
well [inaudible] does a clearing in the animals come out to eat the sprout.
The new new new growth grows up.
Yeah.
And it's a big open place so it gets plenty of rain and sunlight.
Like sometimes the canopy keeps like smaller things from growing.
You don't get enough sunlight.
And a lot of times in the canopy too,
like everything's beaten down with,
um,
pine needles.
Everything's covered with leaves and shit inside.
When you have a real thick forest,
right?
Those big open areas,
mantle,
these animals come out and you could find it in there.
That's fucking mild,
easy hunting season.
Wow.
It's never easy.
They could smell you fucking impossible distance way you put stuff on yourself
too,
to not smell like,
no,
you can't do it if you can't cover up the smell,
no chance.
The only thing you could do is there's a thing called,
oh,
Zonix that does work,
but it only works if you're in one place.
So like if you're in a tree stand,
you have a thing that you put above your head and it sheds ozone down on your
body.
And with the ozone does,
and this is how it's been explained to me.
Again,
remember I'm a moron.
Say you're talking to him like I'm an idiot.
I'm like,
I tell him like [inaudible] I went to Boston University,
Umass Boston rather for three years in their continuing education program and
everyone took my sats.
I'm a legitimate moron,
but apparently this ozone shit that comes down over you,
it uh,
it confuses the deer.
Like the deer gets a set.
It's like,
what the fuck is that?
Right?
He doesn't know what it is as opposed to smelling you and go on fuck.
They smell you.
They just run,
they smell people.
They just run.
Yeah,
they take off run like hundreds of yards away.
You'll see them just go like this and then just take off and you're like,
what happened?
And you blow some um,
this like a white talc in the air,
like a puff of Talc.
And as it drifts,
you see which way the wind's blowing.
It's a wind checker,
right?
So when you're up there in the wind,
you have this like little,
it's like a,
like a,
almost like a little baby powder title meal and you just press it and the stuff
goes in the air and you could see exactly where they went.
They even have vaporizers now that do it.
Now I have one that's like a vaporizer.
You press a button and just missed it,
goes in the air to show you where the windows and just missed out.
Yeah,
it's wow.
And um,
it's just for that just to make smoke so you could see which way the smoke goes,
but it's just missed the ozone shit.
Three yields on bonds,
your scent molecules.
Yeah.
So this is what they're saying.
So that I don't think they're allowed to lie about this shit.
I think in this day and age it creates like a shield for your,
your natural,
your odor or odor,
natural odor.
So,
um,
my friend John Dudley is a big believer in this and anything he's a big believer
in,
I'm a big believer in that is fucking wild.
Apparently it does work,
but it's still,
if they see you move,
if something funky comes their way,
I mean maybe it works for like 80% of the time,
dear,
or some sneaky fucks.
They're smart.
How good is their vision?
Their vision is good,
but they,
they,
you view things like from an edge detection thing like that,
they see things that move.
Right.
So if you just freeze,
if you have camouflage on and you freeze,
they will often walk right by you.
That's fucking wild.
Especially if you had,
there's a thing that's another thing called the heck suit.
Hecs and a heck suit.
I wear one.
I don't know if they really work,
but they appear to work with birds like they've proven that birds follow in
electrical magnetic signal.
That's how they get home.
Right?
They use the,
the,
the natural magnetism of the earth to figure out where the fuck they're going.
Like they did 10 sounds crazy.
What isn't that funny that we can't do that.
We're so stupid.
We can't get home of fuck it.
I'm lost.
Yeah.
We can just use our two wrong terms.
I'm fucked though.
But these birds,
it's like it works with birds.
Like all these guys say that you put these suits on,
birds have no idea you're there.
They don't see you like it blocks the electrical magnetic signal that your
body's is be made out of.
What's that?
It's a mesh.
There's some sort of a mesh that the yaks yeah,
the blocks that they have actually been like meters they can show.
They put it on and wave it over this thing.
There's no reaction.
Take it off and then there's a reaction towards detecting the signal that your,
your body puts out.
The real question is that it proved that it does that.
The real questions can animals really see it and how many of them can see it?
The big thing is smell.
It doesn't matter if they can't see you.
If they fucking smell you,
they're gone.
So you could look just like a tree,
but if a deer smells and he's going to just start running,
they just run.
What's your,
what's the only fixed for the smell thing?
Other than that,
that,
that thing.
That's it.
There's so their,
their sense of smell is impossible to understand.
The,
it's so much better than ours that what we have shouldn't even be called a sense
of smell.
It'd be like the difference.
You look at the hallways,
hallways,
face holes.
Yeah.
Like how,
how?
Well,
the ants do stand up comedy like
beds in comparison.
Couple of good attitude.
A couple of guys got to get kind with an ass man.
I gotta get tight three but that's what the difference is in comparison to like
how bad our noses work versus a deer.
Who's the bet?
What animals the best?
I think a bear bears are the best sense of smell.
I think bears have a preposterous sense of smell.
Dogs are really good,
but it's not that good.
I think a bear is like a hundred times stronger than a bloodhound fucked up.
Fuck.
You can smell something FY eight they could smell 18 miles away.
You can go straight fucking Milo.
Ro.
I search where the average US sight distances.
How far can people,
what's a,
what's a typical like sight tests?
No one can only see about a mile,
right?
Depends on the animal.
Like some animals don't see good at all.
Like pigs don't see good at all.
Yeah,
you just freeze on a pig.
They don't know what the fuck's going on.
For sure.
Eagle Eagle,
I like little mice in the fucking Egos have the best.
Probably site.
Yeah,
they can see from miles and miles a mile.
My friend from Alaska,
he goes halibut fishing all the time.
He said,
if you love how you're pulling a fish up in eagle can see it miles away.
That's it.
That,
that's some dinosaur shit.
That's how you know dinosaurs shit does.
That play is miles.
What grizzly can find an elk carcass when it's underwater and polar bears can
smell a seal through three feet of ice.
Fuck,
three fucking feet of ice.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
Three feet of ice.
That is a fucking monster.
Imagine if you were in a big concrete building.
It's three feet thick and there's a bear on the outside.
If that was a monster movie,
be like,
this is insane.
This monster.
No,
I'm here like you'd be two kids right there.
Their parents have already been killed and it was just breathing like,
don't worry,
we're safe.
It's concretes three feet thick because no way could smell us in.
It's outside.
I smell who he talks to.
One
just just wanting three fucking you and your sister.
18 miles of smell.
Three feet of smell through eyes.
Did you ever see the video where the BBC reporter gets inside a box like a
plexiglass box?
No.
They put him around polar bears and the polar bear tries to eat them and the
polar bears trying to eat him through this box.
Try and figure out how to get to him because it knows he's in this box.
It is fucking terrible.
Why would you ever Bro in?
This guy's got cameras on him the whole time.
Shush.
Shitness man's Dukie and left in bright fill in those drawers,
son.
How strong is that?
That thing has to be indestructable.
They're so big.
They're so big and we've been,
we've been really fucked over.
Just let it out.
Let Ron Jamia we've been really fucked over with Goddamn Klondike bars and Coca
Cola and made it look suite.
We have a super distorted perception of this fucking predatory killing machine
that eats its babies,
bro.
Bro.
These things are fucking ruthless.
Like they're that cleanup crew.
They're there to make sure there's so few resources up there in the wild that
this giant behemoth of a bear exist.
So he could just Jack everything,
just jack everything and keep the populations nice and low.
Look at that.
He's in.
You're right in there.
I'm not a biologist so that he knows it's in there and he's just trying to get
at it.
He's biting it.
God Damn,
dude,
that would fuck that up.
Look at this man.
It's pressing on it.
That's glass,
man.
If you're crazy,
you're fucking dead fucking teeth through it.
When it's opening its mouth,
that's a monster's mouth.
This is what I look like drunk at a Mcdonald's had fucking four in the morning
trying to get food to the drive through
this poor guy.
He's behind him.
He was like,
but the camera is this way or shaken.
Shaken the shit out of it.
Of course it is.
Why would he be so convinced that that can,
that thing would survive.
It'd be so dope if it just of,
how do they rescue this cat?
This dude?
Yeah.
How do they get him out of there?
Like who's who's like how long does it take to get him out of there?
They got to find a way to distract this bear walked away.
Come on.
It's got to get frustrated at some point.
I'm like,
fucked us.
Look at it.
He goes,
fuck dose.
But how did they test that box?
What is that guy hated him.
The guy who made the box.
Oh,
this guy's going to climb out.
I'm out.
I'm free.
We've got a prize.
Hug The bear.
Yeah.
Like let's pretend the bears right there,
right next to him.
That thing can run 35 miles an hour.
Fuck Outta here.
Here's how fast the bear run there and saying,
dude,
they run like that on ice.
That's things just digging with their claws.
They could run like hell.
They'd pick,
kind of pretended like that was a totally safe,
normal experiment for him to do.
Like he got out like no big deal,
man.
You know,
fucking polar bears.
Ironically our black underneath all that white,
furry,
you know that,
right?
Let's clear those clearer.
Is that just a clear black?
It's black skin.
The skin's black wire.
Yeah,
it is.
Wow.
Well you got to imagine that people get Snow Tan,
right?
You get snow blind blind because the sun beating off the snow.
Like people get burned like really bad.
Yeah.
And go skiing without chilling.
That's got a polar bear.
It looks no,
that's a black bear bro.
Polar bear without here.
Yeah,
but it's not.
Look at the hair around his face.
See how it's all black?
A guarantee.
That's a black bear also.
It just doesn't look big enough.
What does a bear,
maybe it's just another one.
It's got main,
but you can see how it has the hair on the top of his heads.
Black at the sink.
I think someone just wrote that and it doesn't mean that it's correct,
but they are.
They're dark.
But underneath all that,
they are really dark,
dark.
It's wavy.
Hey,
maybe when they get mains,
their fucking hair on their head gets black.
Who the fuck knows who go to that?
Well,
ranges.
Ranges.
Weird Shit.
What the fuck is that fair?
I mean I've looked,
I've seen this before.
I guess I did.
I typed in polar bears popped up.
What would imagine pulling up?
They're know for their,
the most terrifying cause they're the biggest well there,
right there,
Jamie top.
The top fourth picture is them spreading the hair apart.
Right.
They,
you see the skin there,
so there you go.
Oh perfect.
Yeah.
And see how the hair looks white.
But it's actually,
they say it's like more of like a clear color.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy to me.
Yeah.
Like not technically white.
No,
it's,
yeah,
it does.
It does.
It looks translucent.
Translucent almost.
Right.
But what an amazing animal man.
Unbelievable.
Imagine that thing lives in this place where there's no vegetables at all.
Nope.
But it got so big,
it evolved to get that big meet.
Duke just meet tons and tons and tons of me and they can eat a fucking like a
hole through ice to get to you too.
It would just chew through the ice.
It'll do whatever it can to,
it gets you right there.
It's so nice that they're so far away.
They swim.
You know,
they jumped in the water and swim.
You can swim six miles an hour,
bro.
And for how long can they swim?
I wonder how long they can stay in the water for cause they have to get out of
something that knots and why do we need knots?
Boat,
boat.
People love that shit with boat people.
Hey,
it's six fathoms.
Hey fuck face.
How many feet?
5.2 knots.
5.2 knots is a mile.
Six miles an hour.
Six miles.
Now it's 5.2 nuns.
My boat goes five notes close.
Want to make it slower?
That's so confusing.
Why would they do that when they can just do miles an hour?
What is knots?
I think not around before.
Miles an hour.
Kilometers,
kilometers.
We're also before miles an hour was it?
Yeah.
Kilometers.
Kilometers with the metric system and that that was later.
No,
no knots or kilometers.
Then where else really smart people are like,
why the fuck are they talking
about kilometers?
Some engineer is like,
God dammit.
Well when I was in high school,
they tried to put the metric system on us.
They tried to bring back the metric system and we're like,
bitches as America,
fuck that and fuck your systems of 10 we leave out unnecessary letters to maybe
not,
oh nevermind.
Sorry.
It didn't work.
Just like soccer.
They tried to push soccer on us too.
You know why soccer didn't work.
We were talking,
I was talking about this today because this is America too slow.
Too slow.
Slow too slow.
Baseball works.
What people say,
people have goals.
People don't goals too.
People have goals.
Oh,
okay.
So people have scoring,
scoring.
People would up scorps listen,
the NHL where you're saying the reason they changed the Blue Line rule is
because they wanted more goals so they got more goals,
more viewership.
What's more American than a Grand Slam?
Right.
Literally nothing bases loaded crack.
It's all sports center used to be home runs and dunks.
Yes.
Fucking should be.
We love,
we love seeing that moment.
Yeah,
so in soccer,
but you have 90 minutes and sometimes no goals.
I get it.
I can't do it.
If you understand how difficult it is,
if you're a of the game,
if you love the game,
play the game.
Like Ian loves it.
Yeah,
he does.
He knows the only black I know that loves soccer in America.
Is that real in America?
How many black fucking friends you have that love soccer?
He's my only one.
That's true.
I don't have any black friends that watch soccer.
He's,
he's literally my only will make it right though.
Yes.
And England.
He lives in England as well.
England,
Jamaica,
right.
Born in Jamaica,
then moved to England in New York.
Have you seen those games?
He goes to,
they look awesome.
We were supposed to go.
I'm not taking their fucking fun.
It's just,
it's not,
I don't,
it's not my ship.
We were organized in the comedian thing,
but I had a family thing that I would do.
I couldn't make it,
but they look like good time,
especially if you want to get blasted on some of this.
Uh,
Mike Tyson,
we that we smoke today.
It's the fucking delicious by the way.
Thank you Mike.
Thank you,
Mike.
Thank you.
My shout out to the champ,
the motherfucking champ.
Um,
what were we just talking about?
Polar bears.
Yeah,
man.
There was not,
somebody wrote some article about polar bears.
Uh,
you know,
when,
whenever we say that polar bear populations are threatened,
they definitely are in certain spots.
But the places where polar bears occupied is enormous.
Yeah,
it's huge.
And in some areas there's a lot of them.
And we have this non nuanced way of looking at polar bears.
So people would get really mad if,
like,
they found that these Inuits were killing polar bears.
But sometimes these folks are living in places where polar bears are entering
their villages and they are super dangerous killing their babies.
They'll kill people.
They will straight up kill people.
You know,
I think there's a comic who's a,
um,
he's,
uh,
also a veterinarian.
Kevin,
he's a vet.
Yeah.
He's,
um,
he's a guy who performed in Denver.
I met him in Denver.
I was working with them when,
Oh,
do you know him?
Yeah.
He's,
he's famous and Dandruff.
Fitzgerald.
Yes.
He has a TV show out there.
Fitzgerald.
Yeah.
I was gonna say Fitzgerald,
but I thought it was wrong because my friend Dave Fitzgerald,
that was just tossing and long white hair.
Yeah,
like yeah,
he told me that polar bears out of the womb or like Predator,
you know like the movie Predator,
like out of the womb,
they're just trying to bite and kill out of the womb dope.
I had the wound,
they just come out and I was like,
well,
it makes sense,
right?
If you stop and think about what their life is,
everything is just white and frozen and occasionally catch something slipping.
They occasionally get someone whose son named themselves and you get to them
before they can get away and you could dive in the water and grab a foot and
drag them back up.
Survival man.
The darkest store that I've ever heard,
I don't know if this is true,
but let's pretend it is.
Yeah,
fine.
Was there was some sort of an expedition and there a boat hit some ice and so
their boat started sinking and they had a real problem because the next boat was
hours away.
So they call in a May Day for the next boat and they climb out of the boat in
time before it sinks and then they get to an ice shelter,
like a,
an ice raft.
A Nice island.
An island.
Yeah.
Last island and distance.
I see a
polar bear,
huck,
and it's many,
many ice land bridges or whatever.
The phone over ice distance that ice island away.
High steps,
but it keeps jumping in the water and getting closer on.
Fuck.
He's trying to figure out what the fuck they are and then filing against to
them,
finds out what they are.
It's in the Ice Island next to them,
jumps in the water,
pops up,
grabs one guys.
There's nothing in where they can do about it.
Fuck takes him,
kills him,
dragged him in the water again,
it goes back on the other ice island.
Just starts eating them and they're just chilling,
watching it.
And there are one ice island away hoping that he doesn't stay hungry after eats
their friend elbows.
Your least favorite friend and the boat comes and rescues.
Fuck me dude.
And they had to watch her.
Frank get eaten alive.
The friend got eaten alive.
He died.
Probably quit it probably.
It probably ate them in front of them.
It probably took us so they could see it.
He didn't care.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Like he'll eat worry when you eat a clam that you're eating in front of other
claims in front of Napster.
I'm sure he,
fuck,
I'm sure the bear ate it to know they want to heap.
I'm saying he kept an eye on them.
Yes.
As like your next dude.
Well he probably knows that they're there.
If this isn't enough,
you me,
maybe the guy is like a small guy.
What do you do?
You,
what do you do it?
You just sit there and watch it.
You jump in the water.
What do you,
what do you fucking do?
You can't swim away.
You'll freeze to death if you get in that water.
You just kind of sit,
sit up.
The fact that if a chooses to kill you,
that's your time.
There's nothing else you can do.
You can't fight it off.
I would punch my buddy and knock them out so it's easier than,
you know what I mean?
Knock 'em out,
buddy.
Huh?
You have to think about how much you love your friends.
Oh my God.
There's so many people I'd knock out,
Lee for bears to eat.
There's,
yeah,
there's a lot of people.
Most most of my friends I know,
but what it is,
is just,
it's,
it's an escapable with the power that it has.
Have you had a moment of near death experience?
Never like that.
Never.
Never around the animal like that.
Have you ever had a near death experience where you're like,
fuck,
I could die.
Car Accidents.
Yeah.
That's the only time I thought I might say this is kind of a near death
experience.
It is.
Never know.
Have you not been in a bad one?
I've been in some bad ones.
I've been lucky.
That's near death shit.
Yeah.
You ever ride bikes?
Motorcycles?
No one's gonna know that's your desk show.
People I knew crashed in one person I knew,
saw someone get hit all in like a month.
It was like bang,
Bang.
So to people I know crash fuck themselves up.
One was the dude that I was working with,
m and A.
Another was a frank mir was fighting in the UFC.
He was uh,
you know,
one of the best heavyweights in the planet and some guy ran a red light and t
boned them,
snapped his leg in half,
sent him flying through the air.
It had a real problem.
I mean,
he almost lost his leg,
man.
Nobody's lucky lived.
But the femurs like the big upper leg,
that's a really bad bone to break man.
Usually.
Yeah,
it takes a long time to heal.
It's very dangerous.
A lot of,
a lot of blood flows through that area.
The main arteries they can fuck it takes a long time for that leg comes back.
And for frank,
it was years before he was like 100% again and arguably he never was the same.
It's arguable that something like that you're,
you're always going to be like playing catch up you guys.
It's such a devastating injury.
Lots.
Fuck.
I mean,
sounds like fuck motorcycles man.
It's too much on protecting.
Yeah.
Woo.
I'm fucking on the outside man.
But we lived in,
well I was gonna say if you lived in a rural area,
but did you hear about that guy that plowed into these bikers?
He was in a pickup truck.
Yeah.
It was in a pickup truck in New Hampshire and there was this,
uh,
I think they call themselves the jar head bike club or something like that.
A bunch of marines that got together and rode their bikes around and this guy
plowed into them and killed like seven on purpose.
No,
I don't know what happened.
I don't know.
I don't know if he was being careless.
If,
if he was speeding.
I don't know.
It's fucked up,
dude.
Where was New Hampshire?
New Hampshire.
So I was going to say,
yeah,
I drive a motorcycle on some rural road,
but at some rural roads you gotta worry about people not paying attention.
Right.
You move out to the middle of nowhere.
You still don't fucking know Stephen King.
Remember what happened to him?
Stephen King got hit by a guy who was a,
I think he like,
he dropped something in his car and so he was leaning over to pick up whatever
the fuck he left and his vans.
Stephen King was walking by the side of the road.
Maybe it was his dog.
I feel like maybe it was his dog was doing something.
Anyway,
the guy wasn't looking and hit him and it just broke everything.
Damion,
his whole body was broken.
He had several broken bones who's fucked up for a long time.
It took him forever before he could just sit at his desk again and right and he
details it and great and great detail and it talks about in his book on writing
as well.
That's him with pins in his leg.
I mean there's that dog and dude,
he was older at the time.
I mean he wasn't a young guy.
He's always looked old for some reason to Stephen King has always looked like
every time I see a photo I'm like,
what is he fucking,
he's always 50 he's been 50 since he was born.
Well Bro,
if you carrying around that kind of eagle inside your bag,
that's what I'm saying.
Right.
That fucked up shit as made him look old.
Always that guy.
What is this Stephen King calls?
Maybe it's not his strange.
Let's not go down a little Google rabbit hole
forever.
Stephen King me think about how many amazing books that guy is written.
Think about the diversity of them by the way.
Yeah,
they're not all the same.
Kind of like people always go like Stephen King whore.
He's done with drama.
He's done a lot of different kinds of different things,
but you know what I like?
He almost always made it a writer from Maine.
It was the guy from Maine and then this crazy shit would happen to him.
That's fucking like many of his stories.
Not all of them,
but many,
many stories.
Where a guy from Maine did he write Shawshank redemption?
Yup.
Right.
Based off at least.
Yeah,
Dude.
You know what,
I love the story,
but to think about that the,
he wrote that,
that beautiful and the rest of his shit is very dark.
So much of us as black is nice.
Got so much good stuff,
man.
I mean,
he's got so much good.
Did you ever read the Tommy knockers?
It's fun,
man.
It's about,
uh,
like an alien that the crash
lands in the woods and a,
I don't want to give any spoilers.
[inaudible] starts changing people.
What is Tommy knocker mean?
What the fuck?
I don't know,
but I think it was based on some like old fairy tale that people tell us.
Learning the old words like that.
Tom,
Tom Walker,
find out what it is.
Let's find out what this word.
Hey,
I want,
I have a word for you.
Like a,
like Candyman,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Here's a word.
I have a word for you.
There was a word that I heard that I thought it was very funny that I wrote down
that I was like,
oh Joel,
think that's fucking wild.
But I like when I learned a new word,
I go,
oh,
that's fucking,
I always admire you again.
When I see you,
I'll realize no case.
I don't give a few rocks.
No case.
Jamie.
Jamie rocks.
No case to.
He's recently along this whole phone since I got the gold one.
The new iPhone.
How many months has it been since you've been rocking notes?
October.
Do you feel free?
You feel better?
I've only,
I only had the case for one phone.
I guess.
You feel better than other people?
No,
I would not feel riskier.
I would feel like more like you're really living on every day you make it a
success.
I so admire how Neil degrasse Tyson explained it when he's twirling it around
his fingers.
I've made some catches that may be is gained ability because of doing that.
Right.
Otherwise I might just let it drop if it was in one of them,
like odd or cases or something.
Otterbox and thick ones.
This doesn't ever,
I,
I've said that.
I said the same thing,
not to cop and Neil degrasse Tyson Shit,
but I love,
love the design of this.
Yes.
If I don't want to be,
you've always said you love that.
I love,
it's beautiful and I see people with these huge cases,
otterbox and care,
so fucking throat off a cliff.
What am I throwing my phone off?
I fucking Gli.
Are you throwing your phone?
But also what?
Sorry,
got Tommy knockers guy.
But also by the way,
we're all stoned folks,
but also I think about it in the sense of,
I know this sounds privileged,
fine,
but I have apple care,
which isn't that expensive or you,
if it's like 20 bucks,
what the fuck you're take that.
Jeez,
I don't give a fuck Joe Rogan.
You don't give a fuck.
What does Tommy know?
It's based off of knockers who would've been minors trapped in a cave and
would've been pounding on rocks to get rescued in his book?
It's the aliens underground who are trapping on knocking on,
oh,
you should try it.
I don't remember the exact premise.
I knew that they were doing something that was changing the people.
They made a really kind of funky movie.
It wasn't like the best movie.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a good film.
TV.
Fucking was it for TV series for TV?
How many episodes?
Four or five.
I don't.
It's one of those ones where you almost got an imagine in your head and that's
an asshole thing to say cause like,
like I used to have a joke about game of Thrones.
People say he's booked voter.
I'm like how is that possible?
You watching real dragons and people fucking and then sword fight.
It's impossible and you're going to tell me that shows two episodes.
So two hours.
That movie,
if you wanted to really figure out what the book is,
it would have to be hours and hours and hours.
That book was
nuanced.
The book got into psychology.
What was the other one?
Where the dudes were in the woods in some alien crawled inside that guy's ass
hole and killed them.
Which one was that one?
Yeah.
Family Reunion.
No,
there was like some alien thing.
I crawled in his ass and kill them.
Yeah.
It would take over these people who would take over these people.
It was in the,
in the guy's toilet.
You know who it was?
It was the guy who was in that,
a HBO series.
A homeland.
Oh.
Uh,
Mandy Patinkin knows the guy who was captured.
He was captured and he was turned over the red headed dude.
What the fuck is that guy's name?
What the fuck is that guy talking about?
But this is a newer case.
We can figure this out.
We're going to get to this part over this.
Well,
it that,
first of all,
that guy,
find out the TV,
show homeland for season and then you'll find the guy's name.
He's on billions.
Billions.
That's right.
That guy cause an awesome actor.
You know that guy has an English accent.
Yeah.
Does,
yeah.
Crazy.
I know that as good as he is and I can even in American,
that's creepy.
Well,
it's Kinda like,
what's his name?
Uh,
walking dead guy.
Yeah.
Same Guy.
I mean,
same thing.
How are you dare you're wait,
we also false.
Me and Louis.
Damian Lewis and Lewis.
Okay.
Go to Damien Lewis's IMD B and there was a movie that he did a few years back.
There was a good fucking movie.
It was a Stephen and candid.
I wasn't in the right one,
I just never heard of.
It's called dream catcher.
Dream catcher.
I was thinking white trash.
That's why I was thinking white trash.
I was like,
why trash white trash trailer,
trash dream catcher.
Same kind of thing though.
You know that is true dream catchers.
That is the Barb wire around the bicep.
Tattoo of the house of couture myths.
Catcher.
Yeah.
Why do people love people love whenever you see someone had one,
you were like,
fuck man.
Bummer,
bummer.
My kids were shells.
Yeah.
When you had your child,
when your child just learns about the world,
it's just not a good piece of art.
I'm sorry.
Adults think it's one or framed cuts or sucks.
Yeah,
right.
You notice everyone that catches a drug that has a dream catcher hasn't caught
one dream yet.
They're fucking shit.
It's true.
It's a dream thief to dreams.
Dreams.
Yeah.
Catches him,
but you don't fucking get them dumb in front a girls house.
Imagine if you were single and after all this conversation,
the girl you dreams,
goddamn dream catcher over the bed and you're like,
fuck,
she's perfect in every single way.
But she,
she believes in astrology and she has a to of catcher.
It's my,
it was so right.
It was exactly who I am.
She makes you said I was smart and creative and gifted and that I'm beyond
generous to my friends.
Just totally true.
She will not see that rubbed.
Uh,
what is the crystals are gems in your hand before you fuck.
She's like,
can you roll these in your risks before we,
we'll do a match your intentions.
They'll change colors.
If you're really your true self,
be me.
I'll be you,
bro.
How often when you,
when somebody goes,
what's your astrological side?
I'm always like,
oh,
get the fuck up.
Get the fuck away from me.
Yeah,
but I am a Leo and Leo's are supposed to be kind of Douchey and a little bit of
a way.
Oh,
well they're the very aggressive.
What is this supposed to be supposed to be like?
Confidence in like them.
Bullshit.
I'm a Libra.
Does that mean I'm like every fucking guy born in October.
That's absurd.
No children form
boys and then you would get banned from Facebook for being racist,
Libra voice.
It'd be all white guys would be like the new proud boys,
not boys by the way.
I can't wait for sober October for me to keep drinking.
I want to come on the show and have a drink just to watch you guys battle
nonsense.
I don't know what we're going to do.
Whatever you do.
I'm still not going to be sober.
It's my birthday month.
I can't fuck with that.
The real problem is the time commitment.
Like I have too many Goddamn Pie.
I've podcasts that are booked all the way up to then and I know there's going to
be a lot of shit I have to do.
I can't dedicate too much time.
I can't do what I did last year.
Let's do the snickers challenge.
I think that's the best way to do it.
Let's do it.
What have you doing different kind of chapter that I know voted,
but what about a different kind of challenge would tap out first,
but you guys keep your fucking shitty headaches.
I'm going to go have a salad.
There's going to,
we're going to do a deep fake.
Somebody with deep fake of Joe eating snickers.
Just fake fucking make it a phony.
That was the other thing.
Like we had an idea of like who can read the most books?
The most pages.
But the problem with that,
Burt would go road road
pound through all the pages.
Number one,
he can't read but he'll lie.
Look,
I asked him if he could do the split goes,
Yo,
can you split?
I go,
I can do this split.
He goes do it.
So I did this basically I was like an inch off the ground and he's like,
oh you really do.
So he went to do it.
He's like,
couldn't do it at all.
He said the girl a montly flexible.
It's not like there was a time in his life we could do the split,
but here he is 44 years old,
fake.
And he can do the splits.
I'm like,
what are you doing bird?
Why would you lie about,
he might seem like a guy that could do this stuff for a guy that's been sitting
on Dick for that many years,
I figured he could do the split,
so you know what I mean?
For bouncing around so much cock.
I'm surprised bird doesn't do the splits.
He's just a funny dude.
I can't.
I can't let that happen now.
Fuck that.
Kayla thought,
well,
I'm going to,
I want to be invited so I can sit with Jamie and have a drink and get high and
while you guys use sober shit,
it has to be some sort of a little test.
You can't,
it just can't be too involved.
I just,
I can't do it anymore.
Yeah.
Get me and Jamie one of those bubbles so we can just get high and drunk and Rolo
.
Yeah,
give me the bubbles,
but it's just the new feature.
The Joe Rogan.
I know.
I love the bubble machine.
First featured and then Duncan Trussell podcast number 1313 it was Duncan's
requests that he be beyond that spiritual number.
Spiritual numbers are really important.
Please spreading around.
Have you ever used acupuncture?
Acupuncture?
I have.
I love it.
Is it legit?
It's legit as fuck.
I love.
Interesting.
It's wonderful.
They say it's legit.
You've never done it?
No.
Yeah,
I did do it once,
but I did it with a dude who did some,
he just was a little,
a little weird.
He wanted you to drink certain herbs and shit and he couldn't tell you why.
I just went to a fire.
I just
want to,
I just went to a fucking dope acupuncturist and got it done and it's great.
Now I my face,
fuck me up.
I didn't like my face was getting fucked me up.
Ooh,
that scared me all over your face everywhere.
No,
no.
Your sinuses while your eyes.
Boop.
Like in your side,
if they could fix your eyes,
if you can make your eyes perfect.
2020 vision like maybe it was slipping.
I'm 1920 I think.
What if it got to like 40,
40,
66,
sorry,
getting tired.
I can see shit through three feet of ice to the opposite or the other way.
What is it like?
No,
eight eight is like the most insane vision ever.
Like is it smaller number?
As small as it is,
the better vision?
Yeah.
So I'm saying 50,
50 bro.
You'd be blind as fuck.
I'm 50,
50.
But all they can do,
they can fix it.
But you got to keep your eyes open.
Like look,
that movie,
um,
clockwork orange pop,
pop your eyes open and just acupro puncture the show your eyeballs.
So are you looking up?
I see these spears coming out of your eyeballs,
so just people get tattoos on their,
on their fucking eyes.
Have you seen that shit?
They get them on the whites of their eyes.
You did a bad thing.
Bad person,
dumb person tattoo.
You're fucking eyeballs day.
I see someone like that.
I a male in your life.
Imagine being that guy's dad.
Imagine being his friend,
but his dad,
like you raised a boy and whatever happened,
whether it is a chemical imbalance or whatever happened,
what happened was it abuse?
What?
I don't know what happened.
Something happened.
People are fucked.
Oh,
oh.
Oh that guy.
Uh,
in San Diego.
I was telling you about this.
A man through sandals at me this weekend at my show.
Yeah.
What happened is when I call them Sandal Steve,
so this is the most,
there's two embarrassing parts of the,
of this story for this man.
The show,
the sunny show was fucking phenomenal in San Diego was so fucking dope.
We sold out the weekend and then Sunday show was incredible.
Everyone's having a good time.
I'm joking around at the end of my show,
very end about people in San Diego think wearing sandals with jeans as
appropriate.
I was like,
that's just that San Diego is like buttoned down,
but I have sandals on his like Douche bags fucking have their toes out but wear
like pants and some guys are gay.
I'm like,
let me guess.
You're wearing jeans with sandals and he put,
brings up the Sandal and I'm like [inaudible] Steve Sound Caesar.
But,
and he goes,
my name is Steve.
And I was like,
this fucking guy,
this fucking guys,
you record this,
that no.
And I fucking wish that was the only one I didn't fucking record course.
That's the universe coursing coursing.
So,
so,
so I turned,
I turned to the left and this dude throws a fucking,
I see it out of the corner of my eye,
but one of the Sandal hit the curtain,
uh,
are actually,
and the lawyer,
they have the old comedy store sign.
Do you know that they bought,
they brought that down.
The old neon?
Yeah.
Had the old neon now hit the neon.
And I was like,
what the fuck was that shit?
And it kind of,
you know when something doesn't register,
cause I was like no way that if he broke the neo do it bro.
Murder.
So I turn and then as I'm turning another sandal gets tossed on stage,
not thrown,
but like tossed.
And I immediately,
I was like,
wait,
what the fuck?
And he's going like this,
ah Bro.
And then fuck staff is coming up and grabbing this fucking moron and two dudes
are standing up in the audience ready to like swing.
Like people were like,
it was a commotion and I was like,
what the fuck did,
he goes,
I'm just kidding around and we can run.
And they were like,
get the fuck out dude.
Get and he goes,
come on man,
I'm a big fan.
I go,
dude,
get the fuck out.
You can't throw shit at me.
Get the fuck out of here.
So they remove the dude.
But the best part or the most unfortunate part is it's his daughter's 21st
birthday and she's a big fan.
Right?
Your Shit had dad through sandals at your fucking do.
So of course if she's listening,
I love you.
Thanks for being a fan.
Sorry your dad as a fucking moron and through a sandals at us cause that's how
you get kicked out.
Dead Sea duty through them at my fucking head.
He,
it missed my head by like a foot and he thinks I'm just kidding around like,
no dude,
that's not funny.
That's what I'm saying.
You can't throw sandals that Pete,
you can can't throw shit at people again,
throw shit up and the poor girl man,
I've never seen someone so embarrassed.
She was getting her purse and shit and she's like,
ah,
you know like wavering through the crowd and the sun is like,
can I get back his sandals?
And I was like,
get the fuck out.
It doesn't usually happen.
Someone's rare,
rare you gotta you gotta do some dumb shit.
It does happen.
Hey Man,
this guy got kicked out.
The improv.
Yeah,
he was heckling everybody and then when I go on stage with me,
he was just so loud and they just grabbed him and I go,
dude,
you kind of shut the fuck up man.
What do you like?
What are you doing?
Are you doing this is ridiculous.
You know you're interrupting.
And they just grabbed him and the lady who was in front of him was,
who's his girlfriend go the kicking them out of sir,
you're going to leave.
She looks at me and she goes,
did you do this?
Do that.
No bitch,
you fucking problem.
He is your life in a nutshell.
You were here with him.
You saw what happened.
You saw me tell the guy what the fuck are you doing man?
Then you saw the staff kick him out.
Then you asked me did I do this?
But you know I didn't do this.
You did this chill.
No,
but imagine the kind of enabling or your right next to the guy who's yelling out
stupid shit interrupting the show.
You're watching the staff come over.
You've watching this guy get kicked out and she looks at me like,
did you do this?
Do this.
You gotta get your life in order,
lady.
Hey,
clean your room.
Clean your room.
Clean your fucking room bits.
That's your problem.
It was so crazy.
I was like,
you saw you were here with me.
Yep.
The crowd was going ape shit.
They was like your fault here.
Those two people,
she thought it was my fault.
Everybody else thought it was hilarious.
The rest of the crowd is so angry at them because it's so indicative of what we
know to be true about certain people.
There are certain people that blame everyone else except themselves.
Totally always watching.
When you watch a guy who said she's,
she's like,
he loves you.
I was like,
Whoa,
he's ruining the fucking show.
Like you just don't come to a show if you can't keep your fucking your,
your Tourette's and check if you just want to scream shit out and just be
acknowledged.
It's crazy.
You're ruining the whole show.
That sounds the same show the Sunday show I was yet.
We were joking around how crazy it was in the middle of a setup.
I'm to,
I'm about to tell a fucking set up and a guy goes,
she had Tito,
what's your favorite thing about San Diego?
And I was like,
what?
What?
And he goes,
I'll just,
I and everybody [inaudible] I mean,
everyone's lightened him up cause they were like,
is this the,
some people get so excited sometimes and I don't,
I love do.
It was a nice dude.
It was just like,
Bro.
Yeah,
yeah.
He got to know the rules of the thing.
You can't just do it.
He's been out by the beach too much.
Those guys.
There's those guys that too much salt air and too much sun and they're cooked.
They're like a slow,
it's like a,
you know how like if you're gonna smoke a piece of fish,
I'll give you,
put your hand in there.
It doesn't even seem like you would do anything.
Right.
You know,
like you seem like you'd be fine.
Yeah,
but you live there forever,
but you can't have to like four or five hours.
It become a smoke piece of fish.
Right.
That's an happens to those dudes.
Brains smoke fish certain amount.
Those guys,
brains that are always by the beach,
they don't drink enough water.
They just get old and leathery and therefore their brains leathery.
Yeah.
Well,
you see them in the outside.
The look,
leathery.
Their brain looks like that too,
man.
Right?
I'm not a doctor there smoked.
They smoked and they come to the show.
They're slowly smoked.
Every man I fucking,
I fucking love.
Who's willing?
I'll fucking love.
You did too,
by the way of so many.
I had a bunch of Mexican fans.
I love my Mexican fans.
Cat showed up in San Diego on all of these dudes ever after the show.
We're like,
you want us to fuck that dude up dog,
the fucking Sandal,
dude.
I was like,
hey man,
am I going to,
you do whatever you want to do.
Don't right now.
Denton.
Don't ask Mexicans to beat up white people right now.
It's a bad time.
I'm imploring all Mexicans to beat up Mexicans.
All this wall talk.
They'll throw in a few extra shots.
Skins should beat up.
Everybody beat up everybody.
Mexicans that Sandra Santina was saying,
they might have my favorite food,
a period about this.
I think my skin's not my favorite food.
Well,
here's the thing.
Honestly,
it really varies.
Like sometimes my favorite food is steak.
Sometimes I fear food is Italian,
but my favorite food when I know I probably shouldn't be net,
but I want to eat it anyway,
is like a languid case.
Dia from a real Mexican joint,
like that place.
I've taken you guys to the one that this is a joint in the valley.
You go there,
they have Mexican,
um,
uh Oh soap operas on TV.
Those girls,
the big tits and the red dresses always,
right?
Yep.
And everyone in there is like locals.
They're like a bunch of dudes who are getting off work or know about.
It's like a real small hole in the wall type place.
Everyone speaks Spanish 100% everything's written in Spanish.
Food is off the fucking charts,
dude.
It's off the charts.
It you get Lang Lang what case at dia,
Bro.
With the spicy sauce.
Don't want to kind of meet as in their language.
Tongue language.
Beef.
It's beef tongue.
Sensational Dude.
It's so good.
I'm going get one of those.
They have all kinds of tacos.
Oh my God.
What's your death row meal then is Mexican and your death row meal before I go
fund really?
Shit probably kill me.
You want me to have a good time eating lobster first?
Fuck you.
I'm meeting death row man.
Shit.
I mean all of that shit.
I'm just thinking of trying to take them one guy out when he tries to get me
from the jail.
That's all my concentration's on.
Come get me,
bitch.
I'm eating.
If you gotta kill me,
come on man.
Not eating a lobster.
Well,
I'm not gonna get a fucking lobster.
I'm trying to figure out a way to kill you.
If they're trying to kill you,
you're trying to figure out where they kill them.
I'm taking somebody's just one guard gets murdered.
Yeah.
That's a good way out.
I'll fuck up one time.
Don't you think you would be thinking that way?
They're going to drag you to your,
unless you did something horrific and you want to die and you know you're
terrible.
What if you were wrongfully accused of,
you're wrong.
If you,
I'm wrongfully accused and I'm on death row.
I'm trying to kill somebody or you kill yourself when they get to you,
but how do you so hard in jail?
They make it real hard.
They keep things from you that you could kill yourself with,
which is horrific,
and it puts you in just the promise.
You could kill somebody else with it,
right?
They left some wire with fucking handles on it.
You're not going to turn that in,
right?
That's going to get,
that's gonna get passed around some,
some dudes are going to die.
Yeah,
but I,
but I do think though,
if death row with death rows coming up on you,
you're thinking a lot differently.
You're not thinking about killing the guards.
You thinking about fucking
please God people,
people find God when they're about to die.
You do.
But the way to avoid those horrific thoughts is to plan a murder.
Just stick.
Like how fast can I get to one of these guys before they can,
they can pile up on me.
I think about what it would take about.
What does it take though to get to that place when you're like,
that's it.
I'm going to have to fucking just kill everyone.
I see shoes cause I'm done.
That's always like the appeal of a show like the punisher,
like the comic book they ever did.
They always did a shit job with that fucking comic book.
I mean I heard the punisher on Netflix is good.
I didn't see that in movies like that had a dolphin Lungren movie and he didn't
even have real stubble.
It's the dumbest shit of all time because by the way,
this was before HCC is feared.
They faked his stubble and obviously fake
VSP coffee grounds.
It looked so bad.
It looks like bad.
Stipple like little rascals.
Sponge dipped it in some dirt and rubbed it on his face and they pretended that
it was a five o'clock shadow.
I mean,
whoever the fucking makeup artists was,
they should've got the fucking academy award for Paris Shit ever.
But it's like almost like they made it a comedy.
It's almost like they know this movie's a piece of Shit and they are gonna make
the makeup so bad and so dumb looking.
Hey,
that's us.
That's us,
dude.
They're going to make the makeup looking so dumb that nobody believes it's real.
Close it up,
buddy young.
He is their doll figure.
It's not clear and it's not clear.
The other thing is not an HD.
Yeah,
well it God damn dude,
it looks so fake.
It's hard to tell,
but that is that you can watch the actual movie.
Did you Google Lundgren?
Fake stubble punished.
I just did punish or just so we could see pictures from,
I didn't want to have anything Dr. Okay.
Just write Dolph Lundgren.
Punish or fake stubble.
Just try that fake stubble.
Can we have that?
Maybe nobody notices but me,
we have that Mike special anymore.
Where is that?
Where is it?
There is,
oh,
the Mike Tyson fashion.
Yeah.
Let's have some more.
That was a close up.
I remember there was a close up.
He was like lying down.
I was like,
this is so fake.
Well,
I mean right there you can tell.
It looks like shit.
It's hard to tell.
Like I remember watching on TV going,
what?
What is this?
That looks bad.
All right.
There you go.
Yeah.
It's much stringy sideburns counting down to it's dusted his face with some
dirt.
It looks like.
It's like when,
uh,
when,
that,
you know what?
That's like one kid in junior high is trying to get facial hair for the first
time
he's got a sniper accentuates.
Yeah.
I've been thinking a rock and a police mustache.
Fuck you.
No Way.
You've got to get a bushy one though.
It's gotta be bullshit.
You've got to get real bullshit.
How about one like Mike Beltrani roll up the fucking,
the hairs grow along.
You've got to get like Woolford Brimley you know,
you've got to get Mike.
You know Mike Beltrani is no,
I'm talking about no,
he's what top MMA referees and,
Whoa,
whoa.
I've seen that dude.
His mustache comes down like this.
Like Cinderella's hair.
He's got like a yeah,
handlebars.
Yeah.
Handlebars Jack.
Dude too.
With crazy ass mustache.
You would do,
you wouldn't fucking do a mustache.
Maybe I'll do one like that.
There's Mike Bell.
Try and look at that shit.
Yes.
Do you have to grow that mustache for decades?
I know,
but how long does it take to grow a mustache?
Like that?
Forever.
But braiding it kind of,
I mean,
dude,
come on,
you get an extension attitude so you could scan some time.
Shit,
I wouldn't lie like that.
I'd wear last extension.
One guy has to have done that one hour fucking mustache.
We've,
yeah,
maybe someone's done that.
Yeah,
I would imagine maybe as trophy or something like that.
Oh,
it's right over here.
The mustache we've,
it's a look.
Right.
But at a certain point in time,
I would imagine you become like prisoner to that look.
Yeah.
The two of you are then forever.
Like I've had a beard for as long as I can remember and so now if I shave it,
I'm fucked.
You can't,
I can't shave this worried about it.
It's Kinda strange that I can never get away from it.
Now this is it.
I didn't think about until you brought it up.
You've never seen me without a beard.
Who's this cat?
This is the,
I remember playing in a band with this guy and I'm pretty sure part of this
we'll play in the band with this guy.
Yes.
This is not on them under the bus.
Not In his band,
but my band played with them.
We opened up for this as a singer from Mudvayne.
Part of it is not real,
but part of it is real.
He does have a really long one,
but I remember seeing it up close like it was like a rope or something like God
damn,
it's crazy how long you can grow a fucking beard.
That's absurd.
That exists.
Like why does hair on the head grow so long?
What does hair and the face grow to those lengths?
It doesn't seem like it'd be useful.
Well,
why would nature do that?
Yeah,
why would we need it?
Because like arm hair doesn't grow that long.
It does need to anymore.
I have a wide,
his beard hair grow long.
An arm hair stops.
Well I think it's,
I think it's probably cause a hole in that weird though.
Well that's like,
you know,
you don't know the crown of the head hair.
You know this head hair here like yes.
This will never ever fall out.
It's,
it's genetically.
Biologically the hairs will never fall out on this crime.
That's right.
When you see someone that anybody says completely bald still here,
we'll have hair right here.
You have to have hair right here.
They'll forever.
That is weird.
But like what I don't understand is like why can the hair on your head gross on
long and the hair your beer gross along,
but your arm here and leg here is always the same legs,
but your pre pubes can get rather unruly.
Jamie starts a trim.
You fucking filthy cont you can get your pubes get out of control.
Jamie.
I will.
Should I say atrocious.
Atrocious.
They get fucking repulsive.
Different kind of here.
Yeah.
It's like Ooh,
bears were,
yes.
Yes.
It's core.
It's angry.
Yeah.
Angry,
protective kind of somebody else.
It's like,
you know what?
It protects you from filthy plus.
It's like,
imagine if there's a reason for it.
Is there a reason why pubic hairs are so thick?
Google that.
What could that fucking be?
Why is it so weird?
I was thinking it's like the thick shield around a wild boars face
before that comes up is why is it curly either.
Why Xero?
Yeah,
because actually if it wasn't [inaudible] decades,
if he went down there,
they're all,
she had her pussy hair was like a wig.
Like,
what is this all stringy and crazy as a part and you're like,
what is happening here?
I left.
I left hair parted pussy.
It's Braitling.
Beltran's beard.
This is dumb picks up.
They used to describe this.
It says that it helps prevent friction,
both freeing courser and thicker and clearly and all this and not the way I
fucked.
What does that even mean?
Friction.
Have you tried to start a fire?
Skin debris like so you get it.
Don't get like a super,
how much hair is on your cock?
Both people.
Both hairs.
It's like Rye bread and velcro against each other.
I suppose that,
that's funny.
It just sticks.
If you were on a few one,
meth and Viagra and you were in the desert,
do you think you can start a fire flux so hard?
You can start a fire.
Oh No,
no.
Water in the air.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Yeah.
You're starting to fire.
If you're rubbing hearted.
Huh?
Your en masse.
It fucking,
you pull,
listen to slap.
Whoo.
I think that,
I think that's,
I think that's better than
I to fiddle.
Yeah.
The bow.
The bow way.
Have you ever started a fire like that?
I've had to try at a camp.
At a summer camp.
We had to do this one.
We had to do a bow one and then we had to do,
um,
the wiggle one with your fingers is ridiculous.
What's,
what's this one?
The Flint.
Flint?
Yeah.
Flint snap ads.
The much more likely one.
Yeah,
that happens.
But this shit,
this bullshit.
So fucking hard.
It's hard.
So hard.
I got to the point where roll down.
It was burnt like it was black.
Look,
you look like what?
It wouldn't catch.
I smelled it.
I was pretty close I think when I did it.
I don't know when I did it but I'm pretty sure it was like preteens.
Yeah.
When you first start those things.
I think I was boy scouts when I was doing that.
You do boy scouts?
I did boy scout for how long?
One year.
How long do you do boy scouts?
Yeah.
How long?
You seem like a long time.
Yeah.
I didn't make it till we blow whatever though.
I love that.
We're strong enough.
Huh?
She was pouring bro.
Dude,
I got fucking kidnapped almost by these criminals,
these little kids I went to,
uh,
I went to boy scouts in Jamaica Plain.
Boston Jamaica plains is like a suburb of Boston.
Not really a suburb was part of the city.
You go to Jamaica,
Queens,
Jamaica,
Jamaica plain in Boston is a,
it's more gentrified now.
White people are spreading out and there was white people.
They're everywhere when I lived there too,
but they were like angry Irish people who will punch in the face.
And I wasn't used to being around people like that.
I lived in San Francisco and then I lived in Florida and then all of a sudden I
lived with these,
uh,
like really wild people.
Men who is my point.
W W w what were we just talking about?
The led me this,
ah,
about your makeup.
What about before that?
About why you're talking about the angry Boston people.
What was it?
A lot the,
we've maybe been told you just ask me a question.
I can't remember what it was.
I had a point,
I had a significant point.
I completely lost.
So we were talking about angry people,
fire building a fire with Cuban boy scouts,
boy scouts.
So I went to camp with these fucking kids that lived in this really tough
neighborhood and there was a lot of Puerto Rican kids and a lot of Italian kids
and there was Irish kids.
It was all ethnicities,
but it was basically like low income people.
And it was the first time I was around kids that were like legitimately
dangerous.
Like when I live in Florida,
we were around like alligators and shit and we used to go into the swamps.
You'd find snapping turtles.
I lived there for a couple of years,
but it didn't seem dangerous in terms of like the kids that I was interacting
with.
Then all of a sudden I was in Jamaica plain and they were dangerous kids,
tough ass kids.
They were tough ass kids.
And um,
I didn't know I'd never had sex and I didn't know like what way a penis goes in.
I didn't know it goes up.
I didn't even consider it.
But this kid names Paulie Hudson,
he lived right next to me,
shamed me.
He goes,
you probably don't even know that a,
a dick goes up in a pussy.
I was like,
he's right.
he does.
I was 11 I was like,
really?
I was trying to like figure out how that would work.
I was like,
ah,
well I guess I wasn't alive.
I was 1313 was when I lived in Boston,
but I was like,
what?
Okay.
I get it checked.
It goes up.
Wow.
You could've said that nicer.
I was like,
yeah,
you can just say Juno
kid that I had ever encountered probably would have said,
hey,
did you know that when you have sex it doesn't go straight in?
Cause when you think about having sex,
you would think your penis would go straightforward.
Yeah.
You think your Dick goes like this?
You go like that.
You'd never think you would go up.
You're like,
oh,
of course.
Why else would boners be like that?
Right,
right.
Wouldn't make sense to do it.
You'd have to hold them down to get him into the proper position.
Okay.
Now.
Anyway,
I went to fucking boy scout camp with these criminals and do the first night.
The first night they tied this kid up and they,
he was sleeping,
he was soundly asleep and he was a little annoying,
but either way they tie this in it up on his Betty,
a little cot and they dragged him into the woods and it was dark as fuck.
It was New Hampshire Woods.
You don't see anything,
no lights.
There was no moon out.
So I mean you couldn't see your fucking hand in front of your face.
It was,
I had never experienced that before and all my,
and I was 13 so in all my life as a person,
I had never been in a place where I couldn't see my hand and I was outside
going,
this is insane.
Because we were like,
this boy scout camp was by a lake way the fuck up in New Hampshire.
And what did they see in their shitty criminal kids
guy?
And they bring them out into the forest and they leave him there.
And then they came from me,
man.
But I woke up and I was like,
fuck you,
fuck you.
And then they took this other guy,
like they left me alone.
I W I just did.
I gave up on all the activities.
I was awake when I heard that kid like mumble and shit,
and I saw them carried away.
I was like,
these guys just trapping this guy down to a cot with fuck.
I don't remember.
They did something.
I do not remember,
but I remember the other kid,
they put toothpaste all over his clothes.
Apparently when you put two spaced,
like toothpaste is not wash out good nicely and 19 whatever the fuck it was.
What was I 13 so was 19 1946 79 I think.
Say 80 79 80 81 I was 14 yeah,
so it's that age 80 [inaudible] and they're like these little fucking crux.
I was out in the woods with these kids and we had bows and arrows and 22 rifles.
You would hear ricochets man,
we would be,
we would be over by the lake because me and this other kid who was also this
kid,
we call them onion.
We went by the lake.
I think it was him.
I is this a Theo von [inaudible] real story
with this other kid who decided to skip out on,
no one cared if you were engaging in all their activity,
no one cared.
Right?
Literally,
I'm telling you,
no one was watching us.
I was 30 we just grabbed fishing rods and we went well went where the lake was.
We knew where the lake was like all these kids would get together and they're
all doing archery and rifle practice and you're hanging out there with a bobber
and the water here.
Zero.
You Chase your fucking rich today.
They let these fucking kids have 20 twos you had and it was the,
it's a weird noise like when you think of a gun,
you think of a boom 22 is like crack,
crack,
crack.
It doesn't feel like it would hurt.
It sounds like a whip slot.
It's not as threatening as the actual action of getting hit by a bullet.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It will kill you sound like what it is.
People kill people at 20 Twos,
22 old fucking kill you.
But it just seemed,
you know,
like he can't be around these kids.
There were y'all am or are you happy that you did boy scouts or not?
Was that fun for you?
One year?
Nobody did anything to me.
Nobody molested me.
I felt like I got off light.
You got molested Jamie out?
No.
How dare you?
That was four years Catholic school,
Bro.
That's where that happened.
That was years later.
You,
you know what though?
I always think about that.
You know,
I went to Catholic school when I was a kid kid and then never again.
I never got molested.
I always think that maybe I wasn't cute enough or something like that.
Was that I just found out
something up online.
Uh,
where I'm from in Columbus,
some list just got released of a bunch of priests that either that have been
either accused and found out that whatever was happened,
some are still alive,
some art.
I looked through the list and found someone that was a priest at my school.
No.
Yeah.
I don't know that any,
none of nobody I know is said they'd been touched anything like that,
but like blew my blue.
All of our minds,
we're like,
holy shit,
it's gross.
That shit is fucking girl.
How much?
It's one of the weirdest things.
You can just connect a thing that's a horrific act to a church.
That's one thing that you just can do.
Yeah.
The Catholic Church,
Catholic priests,
pedophile.
You could just say that.
I mean those tests,
peanut butter and jelly,
Bro,
too.
Right?
How crazy is it that the peanut butter to your jelly is fucking kids
you imagine and kids love peanut butter and Jelly.
If you see a jar jelly,
you think,
Oh,
if I had some peanut butter and some bread and make a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich,
you see a priest,
you're like,
oh,
that guy fucks kids.
He fucks kids.
Isn't that weird?
That's a,
you'll never get away raising.
Just trying to teach the word of the Lord,
man.
Sure you are dude.
How crazy is that?
It'll,
it'll go away at some point.
No,
it will not.
No.
Well not as long as you let those waves keep doing what they're doing.
It will not.
Yeah.
Just can pope himself at one point,
that guy that uh,
Ratzinger in what at one point in his life he was involved in moving people
around.
The dude,
they said he was wanted for crimes against humanity.
That's so fucked.
This one.
There's a documentary that shows that he let these people go and let this one
guy go rather and moved him to another parish where were molested hundred deaf
kids.
Oh Dude.
Jesus Christ.
Oh Shit.
It's pure evil.
It's pure evil and what's most fucked up about it?
It's evil that's coming to people that are looking for God.
Right.
Like the people.
That's why people get mad when you talk shit about the Catholic Church because
there's a lot of great people that are,
yeah.
Not everyone is a shit and all the people that are actually going to the church
or the good people.
Right,
right,
right.
Good priests.
They do exist and not everyone's bad,
but the number that are bad.
Oh,
a hundred desk kids.
Huh?
I mean,
the numbers are insane.
There's,
did you see the documentary here?
New eval?
No.
Are,
did I speak no evil?
Speak?
No.
Which ones?
So my iTunes,
I think I can pull it up.
Pull that shit up,
baby.
I'll publish Udev shit up.
Um,
but it's a horrific documentary.
Speak,
speak.
No,
it's a horrific,
deliver us from evil.
Deliver us from evil.
God.
Damn.
We've got three different titles.
Which one do you like better?
Deliver us from me.
They nailed it.
I think they got it right.
It's a terrible documentary in terms of,
um,
the way it makes you feel.
It makes you feel it's a very good documentary.
Makes you feel terrible.
That reminds me of,
did you watch,
um,
uh,
the devil?
We know which ones that we talking about that.
So we talked about that before.
The devil we know is about,
um,
three m and Teflon.
Oh.
Oh,
you don't know what that shit.
No,
Bro.
Watch Teflon is in 99.99% of the world's blood.
They had to go all the way back to the Korean War to find out Teflon.
Not In someone's blood.
What fact?
Teflon.
The devil we know,
bro.
Watch this fucking documentary cover up.
Did you ever Google?
Um,
the devil we know debunked?
No.
Me Neither this,
but no,
that's what I always do.
Oh,
debunked.
No.
Well,
watch this shit.
It'll give you some believe you some insights heavy to what's really going on.
Even though I'm not doubting them.
Every time I look at anything like this,
now I write debunked and I put it into just to find out and I find out is there
any credible sources?
Sure yet,
and I don't necessarily automatically agree with them,
but are there any credible sources that have any indications?
Trying to find that if there's a balance to it.
I've just said too many things that are not true.
Well,
because nothing comes up.
When I typed that in,
just a story in the La Times that comes up,
variety,
the devil we know or review at nighttime says,
should we be scared of Teflon and documentary,
Blah Blah and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
In this documentary,
there's a farmer that lives down the down the road from where,
and this is 40 years ago,
50 years ago where three m was making Teflon,
right,
and he was complaining to them,
well,
the water starts wasn't supposed to be polluted.
They lied.
They,
they put,
they put their,
their runoff in his water.
Cows had fucking like blue teeth and shit.
Their eyes would turn different colors do to,
he was like,
he kept complaining but they push this,
they pushed him down,
like shut the fuck up out of Arco until he went away.
And then this documentary explores how other people have tried to tell his
story.
But no one gave a shit that Teflon was killing it.
Such a rapid rate for you.
Before I forget this,
hold that thought real quick.
Can you please go?
Cause I keep forgetting this.
Can you please Google that?
MMM.
Water bottles in target and other stores were found with the arsenic.
No.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Levels of arsenic.
An unhealthy levels of arsenic.
Jamie,
you're so good at one hand typing.
It's fucking absurd.
Wizard bottle water and be okay.
Yesterday news.
Yeah.
What does it say?
Can't type with two hands,
Jamie.
Title other than I do.
I'm like this.
I'm like searching pet goddamn popup windows.
Hey,
fuck off the fuck out of here.
And BC news.
Don't fuck Outta here.
NBC.
I don't walk.
Resist.
Hey Jim.
Bottled water brand found to have high levels of arsenic cold from stores.
Find brand particularly.
Oh,
okay.
Here it is.
Penn,
a fee l bothered bottled water sold at target and Walmart.
It's once you name Keurig.
Oh right.
You have to pepper in it cause they merged.
The brand said P,
uh,
Penafiel in Penafiel unflavored mineral.
Spring waters are involved in the market withdrawal.
They wrote a statement there voluntarily pulling the product,
which is sold at target and Walmart.
So maybe like their manufacturer had some fucking weird shit in their water.
They didn't.
Yes.
High levels of ours.
Longterm exposure.
High lives drinking increased risk for diabetes.
Share high blood pressure.
Right?
But they don't say what's the level of arsenic in it?
Right.
What does high level mean?
What would that,
is that how much is okay for us to have there already?
They're allowed to have 10 parts per billion in there and it must,
must have exceeded.
How much is too much?
How much would you snort it off someone's Dick?
Hundred pounds per billion or free?
Zero parts per billion.
Just show me a Dick Bro.
I mean,
how much are you willing to snort if you tell me this,
if you telling me are snakes not bad for you,
how much have you snort?
I'll tell him I'll cut it up.
Would be 12
by tech.
That's fucking insane.
By the way that there was,
there was selling shit that has high arsenic.
Well they didn't know.
I mean it just looks like water and that's the problem with water.
It looks like water.
Like he can get weird shit and water and leave it in a hot car.
Do you know that?
Like you're boiling water bottles?
Yeah,
really bad.
You buy a bottle of water.
Oh,
what the fuck happened that Bob before you,
it's like a adopted dog.
Somebody could've been kicking that thing leaving out in the sun by the time you
get it man.
It's damage to the fuck knows what's in there.
In terms of like diseases,
like you can legitimately have water bottles that leak PCBs.
They,
they leaked some sort of estrogen mimicking chemical.
Really?
Yeah.
The Shit with Justin Trudeau and the water bottle.
Did you see that today?
You do put it up as,
but it wasn't today.
Did he put it up?
Well,
I saw it today.
Did you see it earlier?
Justin Trudeau's asked about how he and his family are doing a better job at not
using plastics.
And his response is so shit fucking awful.
You can't get it out.
He's like,
w w we were using,
uh,
listen to this.
Fucking this,
this made me laugh so hard.
We wait.
Rewind it one more time.
At the beginning at least you and your family do to cut back on plastics.
Uh,
we,
uh,
we have recently switched to drinking water bottles out of water out of a,
when we have water bottles,
uh,
out of a plastic,
sorry,
uh,
away from plastic towards a paper.
Um,
no.
Listen to me.
I don't care.
How tired are now a water out of your marriage?
Will somebody asked me a question like that about my job.
Imagine if somebody said,
hey,
um,
Joe,
what do you think could be done to stop a head trauma in MMA?
And they'd be like,
well,
we could conceivably,
there's not much,
but we could pad the elbows.
We get pad the knees.
We can,
I would have a thought.
Yeah,
I want to fucking thought that shit through.
[inaudible] through it all.
And there's also thinking about getting caught in a lie to the T.
I have plastic everywhere.
Get home.
Please call his wife from the blame on the way home.
Burn up
for us on no plane.
Go to the house.
There's not a fucking bottle in the house.
It's all plastic.
Everything's plastic,
no glass.
They throw their forks with every meal.
They stick them on foot.
They stick them in the sea monkey cage and feed them to turtles.
Fuck you.
Gesture goes houses made of plastic.
His whole house is plastic.
Everything.
You know what he does?
He collect those little things at six packs.
Come with,
hey,
just chuck them in the ocean for a laugh.
He goes to a lake and just puts a bunch of fucking duck killers out there.
Listen,
if you find a male client,
look legit.
Male feminists,
let me let me talk to him because I've never met one.
Every one of them I ever met is this dude's running a scam,
right?
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
I love women.
Sweeties these non male sweeties.
I'm like,
okay,
you're trying too hard,
man.
Something's wrong.
It's so obvious,
man.
There's someone wrote online,
this guy that was like,
it was like,
I'll stand by every woman forever and know that,
and I was like,
craziest guy.
What are you saying?
I was going to stalk you.
He's going to stalk you.
His phone words sound like a normal person's words,
but you just have to have a deep vocabulary of crazy.
That is only that were those combination of words in that circumstance only
exist from the mind of a crazy man.
Yes.
Normal people don't fucking say that shit.
No,
nope.
no,
no sir.
No.
It's super important to tell those guys.
No,
no.
That's why this whole incell thing,
you know about insoles.
Yes.
What to do,
what to do,
what no one wants to fuck them.
What do you do?
Get your shit together.
K.
I went through a six month dry spell when I was 19 and the first time I had sex
with a girl after that I came immediately.
It was depressing.
I stuck in there,
but yeah,
it was sad.
I smelled like desperation.
Okay.
I had very little interaction with regular people.
I was doing was doing martial arts and training and it was meeting girls was
meeting zero girls and when I got together with the girls,
I panicked.
You just jerking off Seavers
um,
I don't remember the truck off feverously and I was that age I went through a
really fucked up time was
uh,
when I was a young teenager where I thought that my desire for sex was a
weakness and then,
and that I should,
I should avoid it.
Who put that in your head?
What?
No one put that in my head.
I put it in my head because it was trying to figure out how to get better at
martial arts.
You,
it something had to help that no,
nothing.
Nothing helped that knows my,
it was pleasure.
That is a desire for pleasure was a weakness.
Wow.
What the fuck did this black,
no,
it wasn't because he was recognizing that like real pleasure.
The only pleasure that I had gotten up to that point was satisfaction in being
good at competition.
So when I started being good at competition,
I rose.
Okay,
what is this is better than anything.
So how do I get successful again?
Well,
one thing you can't do is get wrapped up in anything stupid and you have to stay
mentally strong.
It's like,
why do you want to pleasure?
Like why?
Whooo.
This wound me feel so good.
I felt weak.
I felt like that was a weak thing to want.
That's a lot of good foresight because most kids at that age that our
testosterone levels through the fucking roof or like I want to get good at this
thing,
but also,
oh my God,
I want to fuck everything that walks.
It was also pry.
It had to be flavored by the puritanical shit that I grew up to be some dark to
that but not,
I don't think so man.
Because before that I was really into it.
Once I started fighting I was like,
I,
it was too,
it was also so dangerous that I was always worried about doing something wrong
and getting hit.
And then maybe if I had lived my life correctly,
I wouldn't have gotten hit.
Cause I saw a lot of guys get kicked in the face.
Man.
Let me tell you,
she'd been kicked in the head.
Oh,
I have no idea.
Zero idea a lot.
A bunch of times,
for sure.
Concha Times.
I don't know.
Never unconscious from that.
I'm never unconscious from anything.
I have dropped from a punch and a fight.
I got a t code.
I got dropped in my lap.
It was like he hit me in the jaw and my,
it didn't hurt per se.
It wasn't like,
like sometimes you get hit in the body like a liver shot.
It fucking hurts so bad.
It doesn't matter if you're in the middle of a fight.
It hurts so bad.
But the jaw didn't hurt,
but my legs just stop working.
Like the wind,
they just stopped.
They just shut off and they went out from under me.
It was crazy.
I don't think I'd ever had it happened that way before.
I definitely been dinged or like wobbled,
like covered up and recovered.
I had had that happened before,
but I never had it where I just,
my shit just shut off.
My lights just shut off dude.
But I was still conscious and then I was trying to get up and I was always
looking fucking point,
need any point you do.
They just didn't work in.
Then he hit me a couple more times and it fell again.
The referee stopped the fight.
So that was the worst I'd ever been hit in the head.
Not like you've ever been.
Not enough from Chemo,
but I was always scared of it.
You've been knocked out though?
No.
Never been knocked.
Never once.
No Shit.
No.
How many can see?
How many concussions do you have?
You think on record?
I don't know.
I have three.
I know,
I think to one,
when I was a kid,
I think I,
I know
I cracked my head cause I have a giant scar back there above my hair transplant
scar where it cracked my head on this uh,
cement sewer thing.
There was like some crane,
we were,
kids were running past this thing and something happened.
I don't remember exactly happened,
but involve falling and something slipping and something hitting me in the head
and it hit me in the head pretty fucking hard.
Or,
um,
I didn't go unconscious,
but the whole world went like,
yeah,
I remember,
I remember saying to the doctor that I'd grayed out like a grayed out,
but then it came back like it was a big impact on my head.
So it was that time than the time that I got TK owed.
But then the other times in between,
it was mostly just getting dinged.
We just popped in your legs,
give out a little bit.
Then you cover up and then,
you know,
usually like it's inspiring,
you'll stop.
And it's a,
if it's in a fight,
you get a,
you know,
either either you fall down or you get a standing eight count,
depending on if you're boxing or kickboxing or whatever you're doing.
But in the gym,
you just fight in.
The Gym,
guys get dinged and they go down and nobody does anything to stop it.
And he'd get back up and you're getting hit again.
Like you really probably,
they'd probably should stop the sparring,
but people are,
you know,
guys are fucking animals,
man animals.
And then in a boxing gym when you're allowed to indulge in that sort of animal
behavior,
it gets encouraged,
especially amongst really good guys.
I had my fucking knees taken out from under me.
That's how I had my first concussion.
And I told me about that in basketball.
Right?
Yeah.
That sounds hard on my neck.
Well,
hell on my fucking neck,
hardwood basketball floor.
And I remember vividly to play two moments,
one people telling me to sit down because your natural reaction sometimes when
you get knocked out like that and bounce off your head is to get back up.
You know?
And I could so,
but I was unconsciously doing it.
And then I remember that.
And then I remember the paramedics,
uh,
ask,
asking me to lie down and I remember saying,
I'm gonna throw up.
And I did.
I threw up everywhere and passed out and woke up in the hospital.
I tell him I suck air Mac.
And then in fucking junior high got pops so hard in football.
I got hit so hard.
My Dad was like,
you got your Bell Rung.
I was listening to,
yeah,
work those.
Listen to Bo Jackson.
He's on the meat eater podcast this week and he was saying he wouldn't have his
kids play football.
Not Crazy.
That guy lived through hell.
He has a hilarious,
crazy story.
A person of his life,
but about getting the one time you got chaos in a game,
waking up and going to the wrong side and they tell,
hey motherfucker,
you're on the wrong side.
And then he goes over there and then he hears a gunshot and people sees people
running.
He's like,
who got shot?
He goes,
it's half time.
He thought he was playing the wrong team.
He has a whole various story but it's also kind of dark man.
Like he's talking about crazy.
Wasn't as childhood too,
but um,
did you see that documentary about him or he could shoot bow and Arrow with his
foot.
Kenny.
Really?
Did you not see that bringing that?
You can show that.
Show him that he was saying you got a shoulder replaced.
This mother fucker is an athlete.
To a degree.
That's creepy.
Like keeping the dual sports door as dual sport
athletes.
P everyone thinks they could almost.
No one really can play ball sports now.
He was incredible.
He was unbelievably talented.
But yeah,
there's documenter.
He's living in the woods.
He was fuck he can shoot.
He talking to him.
What was I talking about?
Since he could shoot a bullseye from a hundred yards away with his feet.
Thank you.
That's,
I'm talking about,
I don't know that there's a video of it.
They must have a photo or some shit up there.
That's a fucking this.
But on the documentary [inaudible] 69 minute mark of his 30 for 30 yeah,
it's a,
it was a 30 for 30 that's what was I talking about him though?
I had a great store to media.
What was it?
Crazy knocked out.
Got My concussion about how he wouldn't have his kids play the play sports.
Right.
That's what football is.
Football.
Wow.
Oh my.
I mean,
dude,
football point.
Injurous date of lost it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's insanely dangerous.
It's beautiful,
but fuck me.
It's dangerous.
I mean,
it's so bad.
Oh,
that's that same thing they found in hockey.
The hits are harder than the fights people scared about the fights that hits
caused more concussions by far.
Well the soccer players have problems we can tee because of they get smoked and
they call it a non concuss IV.
Uh,
um,
brain trauma.
The goalie that just one like player of the year,
Robin learners,
his name,
I guess he gave a really good speech about his mental health issues he's been
dealing with.
And while he accepted as a word for Goldie,
I can't find that.
Wow,
this is bunch.
Yeah,
just happened last week.
You were talking to him about his openness to it,
to the whole crowd.
Wow,
that's pretty good moment.
Listen man,
it helps,
right?
It just is not a good thing to be involved with.
Head trauma.
If you can avoid it in life,
it can possibly happen to you in no matter what you do.
I mean anybody can have a head trauma,
it could be an accident.
But if you can find a way to avoid it probably should.
But in these sports you can't.
No you cannot.
So you got to decide whether or not you want to take that risk.
Main line,
he says,
I'm not ashamed to say I'm mentally ill,
but that doesn't mean mentally weak.
That's a fucking dope line,
by the way.
That is a dope line cause I have mental illness.
You Do,
you bitch.
Get it together.
Give it to mental doctor.
I can't show mental illness.
I can have a vitamin for you.
What does it,
uh,
cocaine.
That's what fucked me up by dad was a coke addict going up.
Now we're going to full circle.
Imagine if you were like a,
a slightly overweight person who might be Bert more um,
on the feminine side.
Bert.
And he got really mad at me like they're not perfect.
And I'm talking about Bert.
You said fat guy that doesn't exist.
Love you,
Bert.
Someone that doesn't exist.
If I was an overripe person who was sensitive,
super sensitive,
would you just choose that moment to be a victim?
Yeah.
What'd you,
how would you say,
what would you say you're cruel,
Joe?
Why?
Because you don't respect people like me struggle.
What did you do?
What did I say?
You know what you said you pick,
what did I say?
Fucking Alpha male hit on the case of say
that you just,
I just said something.
You gotta tell me Jamie.
What did I say?
Do you hear what I said?
Offended me.
Pick.
You don't even remember where to tell them what I said called him a bitch or
having mental illness.
Are there some bitches though?
Right?
Okay.
There's a lot of people out there that have mental illness and it's legit.
There's a few bitches that are faking it.
They're just pitches.
Wow.
How come you can't say that?
Because you know it's true.
It's on everyone,
but why?
Look,
there's some people that are just full of shit.
You telling me to anything.
A lot of bullshit.
All the grifters the world.
Some aren't going to claim depressed.
Come on.
They,
they,
they pretend to be heirs.
They pretend to be dukes and they're not going to pretend to be depressed.
It's ridiculous.
Thank guys called a bitch.
It means he's too weak.
It's called a bitch.
It means she's too aggressive to any of us have any idea what this word even
mean?
That it was so good.
That tweet was so good.
I wish I wrote it cause that,
that point is so good.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm glad she put it on Twitter so no one could steal it.
It's almost like that idea.
I like that idea is like very poignant like that.
Yeah.
What is that fucking word?
You know,
like pussy can be great,
but it can also be weak.
But a pussy you can give birth.
I mean,
got an bowling ball comes out of that thing.
Pussies are always strong.
10 pound babies come out of a pussy.
Imagine a 10 pound baby coming out of your Dick and then respect that thing.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
what the Dick's,
what have more props?
Pussy be week.
It's more like compliant,
but it's not weak.
Like it's also a desirable pussy is not desirable to man.
When a guy says instead of desirable calls you a pussy,
what's the first thought?
If someone's like,
oh,
really?
Yeah.
Oh really?
Really?
Yeah.
Right.
So what uh,
when uh,
when a guy calls another guy a pussy,
it's a cheap insult.
Meaning what the Times you ready to fight and you just want to provoke this guy
so pussies the word counter puncher.
So what you're calling a guy,
a great sexual object.
You fucking nice thing I want to fuck.
See,
just letting them know we're about to get down.
Nice thing I want to fuck all the time.
Get over here.
If you watch guys fight,
half of half of it is talking shit to each other before you get down.
Yeah.
Instigate the fight.
There's,
it's not just instigating,
you're getting someone scared.
You making southern girl that you're trying to measure your confidence level
versus there.
Cool.
Who's got the most,
if you can get someone nervous though,
if you can live legitimate,
gets someone nervous,
you can decrease their performance by a significant margin for sure.
It gets in there.
Scare them.
Yeah.
You could scare someone.
Like if you really ready to go,
but you have to be really ready to go.
But everybody,
if you're trying to scare someone,
they took a swing at you.
Tyson talks about it every so many competitors talk to only when they would see
him,
they get nervous that we get scared and they'd fight worse because they get
scared.
Oh,
100% everybody.
I'm you see that guy?
You're like,
he didn't have to talk much.
He,
he let all his performance,
his talk,
you know,
and the most scary thing he ever said,
the scariest thing you ever said was we saw,
how dare they threatened me.
How dare these mere mortals plot out their primitive skills?
Is it crazy that he has such a feminine voice?
He's the masculine dude.
My favorite boxer of all time to watch fucks everybody up because the moments
when he would fight would not just be,
I don't want to say he's like the best boxer of all time.
Who is?
It's either Floyd Mayweather or roared Jones Jr in his prime.
It's how you your tea or sugar ray Leonard or sugary Robinson or
Roberto Duran Goulet arguments or Muhammad Ali who is a lot of boxing guys.
Hey Sugar Ray Robinson,
because he had so many fights and he was so successful and he fought all the
time and he fought the hardest of men in hard,
hard time.
There were different people,
but I say if you had to make sugar ray Robinson,
fight,
Floyd Mayweather,
the box of their prime,
he would box them up.
I think I've,
I think floated box.
This is the argument of every sport ever,
right?
Every song,
whatever.
Who's the best at then?
Oh,
there is none.
I don't think impossible.
I don't think he would be technically at the level.
Uh,
he was ferocious.
He was a vicious knockout puncher.
He threw a double left hook.
Look,
it was nobody's business.
But Floyd Mayweather had a way of making guys look like they didn't belong there
with them.
Oh yeah.
The way he did it to Canelo,
the way he did it to pack you out of the way he did it to Mcgregor Mcgregor was,
was a skillful master.
I went to that fight in Vegas.
Yeah.
I went to that fight for shelf because it's showtime and I gotta Tell Ya,
Floyd Mayweather.
Look like he was fighting a guy who's never fought,
even though Phil,
you know,
he's fought a ton.
It's just he was,
the balance was way different.
He's a master.
He's a true magician to master.
He makes it look simple.
That's disgusting.
Anybody that good,
it looks when people used to watch like Jordan,
you'd be like,
that looks fake.
He's a true man.
It's just so brilliant and smooth and easy and simple and yeah,
it's a beautiful magic trick to make.
You think it's easy.
It's fucking impossible.
What he does,
sugar ray Robinson was a motherfucker,
don't get me wrong,
I just don't think he ever face anybody like Floyd because no one liked Floyd
existed back then because no one liked Floyd could exist in less than a guy like
sugar ray Robinson existed first,
right?
So sugar ray Robinson had to exist.
Roberto Duran had to exist.
Sugar Ray Leonard had to exist.
Uh,
Milton McCrory had to exist.
Donald Curry had exists.
All these killers,
how to exist.
And that way a guy like Floyd Mayweather who is at the tip,
he figured it all out.
He saw it through.
See Robinson was a bad mother fucker to it and he came out a lot of guys,
but he,
they stood in front of each other back then.
Like,
look how these guys are fighting.
They're standing in front of him and cheese and he's marking a man.
I think he was ahead of his time and a lot of ways,
but he lost a Jake Lamata.
And here's my position,
although it may be a controversial one,
I cannot envision a world with Jake Lamata,
outboxes,
Floyd Mayweather.
I just don't see that happening.
But right now you can't control you.
I mean,
you can't compare errors.
Like you can't,
you too hard.
You can't,
it's too hard.
You can't.
So it's like the same way we can't do with comedians.
Like if anybody ever asked me,
I always say that Lenny Bruce is probably the greatest of all time because he
was the first,
he was the guy will in the door.
He was the guy who did the weird shit that we would,
that we do when we say ridiculous,
like we've done on this podcast,
we say ridiculous shit.
And,
and,
and you make it funny and at sometimes at least sometimes it as a point to it
and it makes you reconsider.
But like we hear you're watching Ray Robinson and,
and,
and Jake Lamata.
If Jake Lamata stood like that in front of Floyd Mayweather,
Floyd Mayweather,
would it still be hitting them as 1946 he would still be punching him.
I just,
I think Ray Robinson was the best of his era for sure.
And he was an amazing,
amazing boxer.
But fuck,
but I mean,
a lot of boxing guys like you don't know shit about boxing.
You're right.
I don't,
in comparison to what I know about MMA,
I know he was amazing.
I know.
Who's a result?
The gene foam or knock out the,
the,
the Jake Lamata rematch me and tied up against the ropes and he just beat his
fucking brains out the,
when when he,
he lost a Billy Conn,
he was beating Billy calm,
but he got from heat exhaustion.
I think he and Billy comes a light heavyweight.
He's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He was a bad motherfucker.
I just wouldn't you?
I just don't think you can compare hoists Gracie to Robert Whitaker.
I think they're different animals.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Robert Whitaker's,
the current middle weight champion to hoists Gracie who won the UFC and UFC one
he won in UFC one because Robert Whitaker of 2019 wasn't there.
And how many years ago was UFC?
One was a long time since 1993 so did not,
not even the nothing compared to that.
That was the forties man.
That's what I mean.
Exponentially.
Even more different.
Way Different Way.
Different technology alone has improved so much in the way we train.
How to fight or train,
how to play sports.
It's just continue to watch Roy Jones Jr in his prime.
I mean I saw him fight to,
to Roy Jones Jr when he was in his prime,
did things that even Robinson didn't do,
he would put his hands behind his back.
Right?
What guys [inaudible] on him and Kale with one punch.
Right.
And you'd be like what?
You said a bait.
He would hit guys and it would look like it was an impossible matchup.
Like Vinny pass.
Ian's a fought sugar ray,
or excuse me,
fought Roy Jones Jr and Roy Jones Jr went a full round without getting hit by a
punch.
Joel.
Crazy.
That is almost impossible and a world championship level against the guy who in
Vinny Pazienza was a multiple time world champion.
Does that happen today?
No.
No Way.
He was on another level.
Just couldn't,
he couldn't maintain it.
It didn't maintain it,
you know,
but you can only maintain that for so long.
That's a shooting star,
right?
That's a bad company song,
son.
Right?
Look at this.
This is Roy Jones shoe.
I don't know what can I look at that?
That's James.
Tony.
By the way,
that he did that too,
dude.
Roy Jones Jr was on another planet Sun,
but you don't call it for the stoppage.
When he started fucking up any paths,
he had his arm out.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
this was like one of the beatings all beating.
You see a guy who's at this time,
probably the best ever.
Look at that combination,
son.
Look at that combination with the rest of the referee rescues him.
When Roy Jones June was at his prime.
Everybody's like,
yeah,
but the guys who fought,
they weren't that good bullshit.
He was better than anybody who was so good.
He was on such another level that he made world class fighters look like they,
they weren't that good bro.
He out boxed Bernard Hopkins back then,
you know,
I mean he was on a fucking,
Bernard Hopkins has hard as luck by the way.
Bernard Hopkins who didn't have the same sort of dynamic explosive style.
Bernard Hopkins was a much more solid fundamental guy.
You know,
it was a different kind of style and
Bernard Hopkins Wind up beating Roy as Roy was on the way downhill.
Look at them.
He tells you on shit of Santa right in front of them.
Bank played basketball games like full games.
They'll fight later that day.
Pink Dude,
I'm telling you,
you had to see,
he was almost board for a couple of years because there was a couple of years
where Roy Jones Jr was.
It was just a show na's put him as in a song.
He said the new Mike Tyson is Roy Jones.
But hold on.
You just missed the greatest one of all time.
Go back to that one.
Back it up.
Watch this.
Watch this bunk.
Kao Pans behind his back and he's not even there.
Came behind his back was John Ruiz.
Now this is the fight that fucked him up.
This is why he went all the way up to heavyweight to fight John Ruiz and he got
to like 200 pounds.
And if you look at him,
he's pretty stout.
Then his next fight,
then his next fight.
Look at that.
Come on son.
But his next fight,
he had a fight.
Antonio Tarver and Tarver is a legit
worldclass light heavyweight and and Roy just didn't look the same.
It didn't look the same drop and all that weight coming back from heavyweight to
fight Tarver and Tarver knocked him out.
What's the weight difference that he went down to?
25 pounds?
That's a lot of fucks.
A lot of fucking,
lot of fucking a lot of fun when you're that high up.
Not only that,
let's,
let's be just real here.
Let's be real here.
There's not a lot of ways where a man is thirties gained 25 pounds come on other
than
De de,
De,
de Mexican supplements.
Then in my arm.
Yeah,
dude,
target.
You know what say Tarver said you got excuses tonight,
Roy.
That's what he said to him before when they were facing each other.
But if you look at Roy in his fight,
he just does not look as good.
It just did not look as good.
He w he was more smooth.
He didn't look as muscular and Tara was a real problem.
Man.
Tara was a dangerous guy.
T Roy,
when you're losing that much weight to get down for 200 pounds,
you're fucking depleted,
man.
I don't care what anybody says.
Yeah.
For him to take that fight,
if he was going to do it smart,
he should have been fucking marathon running for like a year or something to try
just try to lose that weight,
but to try to lose 25 pounds of muscle in just a few months time bunk.
That's her right there.
That was the left hand that knocked him out and Tarver was a world class mother
back then.
Tarver might've knocked him out even if they did fight without any problem.
But Roy for sure had a problem.
We had a real hard time making that weight and Tarver was Tara's legit as they
come now.
Roy John Tarver still fighting and Roy Jones Jr just retired Tarver as a
heavyweight now?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He took some time off cause he got caught with
[inaudible] thank
you pad pad.
He got caught with some shit.
Something happened.
And Roy Jones just retired,
Huh?
Yes,
thankfully.
But he was willing to come out of retirement for Michael B.
Jordan.
What he was saying that he could box with them in the cause of the movie creed.
Oh,
moving fuck out here.
And Roy was like legitimately trying to set it up.
Why?
For publicity.
But he was like,
I'm gonna fuck this dude up.
Make a lot of money.
The shit out of him.
What the fuck?
Michael B.
Jordan.
But he was apparently,
he was really legitimately try to set it up.
We made a video where I was,
I was telling Michael B,
Jordan,
please,
I don't care who's talking to you.
Listen to me.
Do not do this yet to not do this.
Do not do this.
Your career.
You have no idea how bad that guy's gonna light you on fire.
He's going to light you on fire.
It is worst days and he's going to,
it was a joke,
but Justin Bieber said he wanted to fight tigers.
Yeah.
Dana White said set it up.
I don't know why he,
why he was joking,
but like the Internet ran with it.
And you know what?
I would love to see that.
That's why he did it.
Because he knows people.
People would pay money.
That's hilarious.
I've watched them the fuck out of that.
But you wouldn't watch that fight.
I guess Tom Cruise was like a high school wrestling state champion or something
like that.
Like,
yeah.
Yes.
Pictures of that for sure.
So why wouldn't you want to watch that?
[inaudible]
55 though.
He's 85 years old and he just broke his ankle doing a movie dope.
And he believes in warlocks.
I want to see him fight a fucking weird.
Okay.
Both super small too.
I don't know how that would like,
it wouldn't be a super interesting [inaudible] I met Justin Bieber when he's a
young fellow,
came to the UFC,
met that.
I've worked for them young.
We did fucking pumped with that kid.
It was so even when he was 16 out of 17 I don't even know what this man,
that ain't a way to do it but if you've got to do it,
he's handled it as good as any.
It's not,
that's not a way to grow up.
It's a terrible way to grow up.
But anybody says that they would handle that differently.
They don't.
They don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
Pretty fucking good job.
I think what would help him for like legitimately help him is a real struggle
like Jujitsu,
like get in the real martial arts.
I don't know if he's into it.
Well that's what I'm saying.
I think he's fighting cause he's training now is he?
I think he offered up a fight because he's learning how to train people talking
shit.
That shit is a motherfucking know.
Look at,
look at,
look at uh,
uh,
Wiz Khalifa when
Wiz Wiz,
the super jacked,
super nice guy.
He used to be thin and now he's like,
fuck that.
I'm going to jack out.
Did you see the podcast I did with them?
We talked about it.
Yeah.
He just really got into it.
You guys,
you guys,
you guys got baked this fuck.
Not as baked as I did with be real.
That's the highest I've ever been in anything.
Be Real size herself.
We were a a barbecued,
we
were barbecuing already and then we like when we get in the car then we're going
to really small.
I'm like,
no
dude,
he doesn't show.
So he does a show about putting like weed and food on vice and those mother
fuckers eat endless amounts of weed on camera.
That's all they do all day.
They smoked joints waiting to eat the weed food.
I was like,
this dude is legit be reels of Jetta Jetta.
He didn't even flinch.
I tapped out like two minutes into the car ride and we're not in the car ride,
but just sitting in a parked car,
but two minutes and to sit in the park car smoking weed.
I'm like,
I can't do this if I'm going to talk.
Yeah.
I mean if you want me to speak English,
I'm going to have to find a chill dad.
I'm like,
I'm going to take a break here.
I was so high.
But those are guys that could smoke blunts to themself.
That's crazy.
That watched me like Dell watch movies with three lip blunts.
Yo,
Star wars one.
This shit looked fake as fuck.
You know?
Um,
what's his name?
uh,
Action Bronson does,
where he gets high and watch ancient aliens.
I was trying to do it last season,
but every time they were doing it I was busy doing something else and I couldn't
do it.
Dude.
He's the best.
They get high and watch ancient aliens to is the best and they sit around in a
green screen.
Yeah,
dude,
that's a show.
Good TV.
That's better than half of the other bullshit that's out there.
That's fun and new.
Well,
it's fun for sure.
Look,
I mean,
you think about if you can have some dude showing up at garage sales trying to
get the best deal.
You can't have action projects
and screen with his homies getting blasted.
C'Mon Bro.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Big Body.
Best,
right dude,
we get his headset.
Got that.
Tommy.
Not,
not,
not really.
Tommy Chong joints right here.
Folks.
Look at,
look at,
look at did DJ outcome as a sleeping on the far right?
He's not even like,
look at him.
He's a good dude.
Action.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
That dude's shit.
Let me see that.
This is the Tommy Chong joint.
Yeah.
Calm,
gentle.
He's smoking a fat one,
but not like that motherfucker.
This is ridiculous.
Unless it's the Tommy Chong joint dropped down to that size.
You're never going to smile.
I'm going to keep it forever.
He's a legend.
Tommy Chong,
he's a legend.
I still listen to his albums when I was a kid,
man.
For me to just even be on a podcast with him was surreal.
I just didn't want to waste his time.
I was just wanting to like be nice to them.
Isn't that weird though for him?
Another podcast for him though,
didn't you?
Isn't that wild?
Doesn't that make you feel type of way where you're like I'm a hero,
this dude.
And he's like,
dude,
I love your shit.
I'm happy and I'm happy that Tommy Chong looks me cause I love him and Cheech
someone's kitchen man.
Yeah,
those guys were heroes,
you know,
like they were ridiculous.
They made everything fun.
There were silly,
like everything was all,
they were getting high and it was silly and I didn't even get high when I loved
them.
When I love,
when I was watching their movies and I was a kid like up in smoke.
What year was that?
[inaudible] 78 77 say okay and find that out and then find out what your big
bamboo came out.
Cause big bamboo was the album that looked like papers.
Right.
And they had it in that paper in there,
didn't they?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think there was a giant piece of paper they did 78 was [inaudible] 78 was
right.
Congratulate 78 and then wait and then,
and then in that album they,
they pro,
they would later put an actual piece of rolling paper in there.
Well the a record sleeve was a rolling,
usable,
rolling papers.
Right.
Gigantism way bigger than that.
That's incredible.
Promoting illegal drugs and you gotta think back marijuana was a full on
schedule one drug schedule,
one schedule one 72 was big bamboo.
Oh Wow.
Big Bamboo was before.
Okay.
So I was three or five is the record six yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There it is.
And there's the fucking rolling paper.
I was five years old.
I was born in 67 this was 72 so that's the rolling paper.
Wow.
They have a real one.
Look at the fucking inside cover.
The picture of the two of them.
That is crazy positive.
When he gets to that picture.
He had a mixture of them.
I pulled up picture.
That's crazy.
Before they were together.
And that Improv group he was in when they were really young.
Like before I,
before that.
Right.
That's crazy.
Is that what that's from?
It's right before that cow.
If I can find it again.
These guys are still doing shows.
Still selling out.
Here's the thing,
Santina and Rogan in 2084 we're going to be taken over fighting over dog.
That'd be taking her vitamins,
man.
Can you believe that though,
that that is,
that's powerful to have that kind of that longterm of effect of being talented
and producing good shit.
Those motherfuckers to be funny and cool for years and years and years.
They still have fans.
I mean,
think about it.
If you have fans from 72 to 2019 kapow named somebody else that's like that.
Who's killing it like that?
Right.
Who would be from that era that still doing what they do in the comedy world
would have been bill Cosby if he didn't have a few.
What did he do?
What he do happen?
I don't remember.
Oh,
you just said that wrong.
Sup Man,
but I mean who sees someone was tweeting from Bill Cosby's account about fathers
,
his wife apparently.
Right?
Isn't that what it was?
Somebody said on the Internet,
his wife goes real men take care of their families
and they imagine generally they raped chickens.
Looking at your computer going,
Yep,
this is a good one.
It's a good idea to put out.
Definitely.
Definitely a good idea to stay relevant.
Yeah.
Not a good idea.
It's a bad rep in prison.
I mean how many rapes you have to have or people forget.
How many rapes does it take to get the center of a jail cell?
What do you got checking?
Hold on.
It's so strange that when I was a kid he was the cleanest,
friendliest like family guy.
He was fat Albert,
he was Jello pudding.
He was like this super sweet,
Nice Guy,
clean,
cut,
clean cut and that's the same thing with like the talking about like the male
feminist that there's guys that want women to do great because it just kind,
they want everybody to do great.
You know what I'm talking about.
But then these guys that are just weasels,
right?
Yes.
Must be similar to those clean cut guys and just really pushing you to not use
such language.
Why would you use a site like that?
Those guys are almost always fucked up.
Of course,
something's up.
Something's that way.
What do you give a fuck about?
People using certain words?
Do not know what a word is.
A word is a vehicle for conveying intent.
Some of them disturb you.
What does what?
What's going on behind your fucking screens?
Brow,
right?
It's happening in there.
When?
When you,
when you deprive people of things,
good God did they want it more and when they show signs of depravity,
that means they,
that's something deep inside of them.
Do you think that everyone who's like squeaky clean is a pervert?
Well,
have some semblance.
Yeah.
Yes,
of course.
When you preach,
when you preach the perfection,
what does that really mean?
Something's wrong with you.
Something's wrong with you,
dude.
Why are you telling me how to be perfect?
Why are you doing me?
How To fucking stop doing heroin?
Are you,
oh,
are you,
Duncan told me this about the Dalai Lama.
Hilarious story that he's blind.
Dalai Lama,
um,
uh,
his,
his mother wants him to quit doing sugar and uh,
he says,
come back in one month.
So it comes back in one month and uh,
he goes,
stop doing sugar.
And the mother's like,
well,
why did you wait a month?
He goes,
I want to see if I could do it.
It's so poignant,
like,
oh yeah,
hey,
you should right.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people telling you that's wild.
Respect women just respect and we want,
that guy just got done screaming.
His ex girlfriend calling her a fucking con,
Oh fuck is dragging you in Twitter.
Fucking bitch fucking pitch.
And then it's like women are goddesses must be respect to those who throw stones
always live in a glass house.
They always do it.
That's the first person to throw something is the first person that's like,
what's really going on with you.
Hey,
by the way,
you see Louie at Skank fest?
Yeah.
What a response.
Interesting.
Our boy,
Tim Dillon tweeted about it and people went after him.
He tweeted best moment of my year or something like that.
You know what someone said to me?
Um,
people lost it.
He said fucking loved him.
Dylan.
Someone
said that,
you know,
hey,
fuck you Joe Rogan.
Uh,
he sexually assaulted women.
Like,
man,
that's,
I understand that people are upset about what he did,
but he did not sexually assault women.
And to say that the one,
the one air,
the one group of people that it really fucks is people who have been actually
sexually assaulted.
Yes.
When it got,
it's not what he does.
Not Good.
When a guy says,
can I jerk off in front of you?
And you say yes,
and he does it,
it is a big,
there's a big difference between that and sexual and contrary to popular
opinion.
Now how many people really know the story?
And again,
not saying that we did was good.
We did was definitely not good when people said no,
he didn't do it.
It's not like he made people do it if they didn't say yes,
he asked questions.
And a lot of people don't know this.
I'm not,
this is not.
And I saw an article in one of these papers,
it was saying that he's changing his story.
He's not changing his story.
What he said was their stories are true,
but in their stories,
he,
I don't think you wanted to defend every single aspect of it,
but as far as I know he didn't.
No one said no and they did it anyway.
That's what I've,
that's all I've ever heard in Sarah Silverman talked about how he would ask her
and she would say yes and he would do it.
Sometimes she would say no.
Right.
Sometimes you want to see you jerk off stop.
But he's a freak.
Okay.
He's a Weirdo.
This is genius comic and I don't think he's as bad as people want to believe.
Yes.
I think he made mistakes like a human and I don't,
you know,
I don't think it was good.
And again,
I don't think he's happy about it at all.
And by everything,
that's a a giant understatement.
But when does it end?
Like,
oh,
that's fine.
Is He allowed to perform?
When is he allowed to perform for people who forgive him?
When,
when is he allowed to perform?
I don't know.
Is the conversation
comes to a point where it's not like you're endorsing terrible behavior,
but you are saying at a certain point in time you got to give someone a way out.
Because if you don't,
then they start to recognize what you are.
Right.
Okay.
And you're kind of a tyrant and you're,
you're kind of saying you don't believe in forgiveness.
You don't believe in improvement.
You don't believe in anybody ever getting past a,
a bad deed that they did.
And I think,
I guess a human who's a kind tree,
try to be a kind person,
try to be a fair person.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta let people grow and move past mistakes.
I don't know when it is and I don't know what someone has to say in order to get
you to forgive it,
but the fact that people dwell on it and unless it's someone,
unless you and him have a personal thing and you want to talk to him about it,
he should sir.
And I don't know if he has,
I don't know if he's done any of that stuff.
But I think as a culture we are way too quick,
not just to condemn but to attack and to continue to attack relentlessly and to
never want someone to get up.
And that's not a sign of a compassionate person.
And maybe it's partly to blame for people who don't express themselves and don't
give you a full version of who they are and you let people contemplate who you
are.
And I think anyone in the public eye has been guilty of that to some extent.
But this is a significant issue.
And I think that people immediately start taking sides and they start going girl
versus boy,
male versus female.
And I think there's real danger in US splitting up like that too.
I think that w w we can't get to this place where women feel like they can't
trust men.
And men feel that if can't trust women just universally.
And then you find rare exceptions.
I've read shit like that before.
Like,
uh,
I read some lady wrote,
it was,
it was kinda sad.
She wrote like any straight white male is trash unless proven otherwise.
It's like,
look,
I know it must be hard.
Okay.
Did I know it must be hard on the same thing to cast such a big net,
not just to even think Filipinos have a bad leg,
but you're abroad.
You're broadcasting it to 6,000 followers either putting that on your Twitter
page,
it's silly.
It's a crazy way of looking at compass.
An entire group of humans ever,
ever forever.
Does that make sense?
Doesn't make sense.
So what the fuck are we like,
look,
I get where they're coming from because they feel like they're gaining ground.
Sure.
So a guy like Louis CK comes back and they're thinking they're connecting them
with Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby.
And I don't think it's the same thing.
And I don't,
I don't,
I can't,
I don't think what he did was good.
Look,
I have all daughters,
man.
Anyway,
jerking off in front of them when they really don't want it.
Sure,
sure.
It's,
it's not good.
I'm sorry about that.
Last summer.
I didn't mean to do that.
That's barbecue till I just thought I'd get time to have a good time.
I didn't feel bad at all.
No,
but fucking come on man.
I just,
I just think that like we have classes of crimes you don't have,
you're not going to do it in this,
in this world.
You know,
you said they're all the same.
And then I heard someone,
I will,
I'll see in someone saying what he did was definitely a crime.
Um,
and I was like,
come on,
you might be upset that he did it,
but it's not a crime.
It's wrong.
It's unfortunate that the real problem,
the real issue is that he was in a position where these girls were admiring him.
Right.
That's the real,
and I think he's recognize that.
I don't think he's explained it to some people's,
uh,
what they desire,
you know,
some people's requirements.
And I appreciate that and I understand that.
Um,
I really just think what a lot of us are missing is just a lack of communication
and compassionate and understanding.
Yeah.
I think we're missing a lot of that.
Totally.
And were real,
you know,
we've got to think of people like anytime someone's,
I mean I'm going to talk about people that are serial killers.
I'm just talking about people who make mistakes.
You've got to treat them.
We're all human beings.
People make mistakes.
We fuck up.
Doesn't mean you're a canceled person.
You got,
we got to stop with that.
I really,
I really think that cause I just think that it's not helping anybody and it's
getting people's jollies off cause they watch someone crashed down.
They have people love to watch someone fucking burned.
And I was also thinking that also when this kind of stuff happens,
people don't want to ever reconsider their opinion on a person.
Like there's this thing about Kevin Spacey and the,
uh,
they made the text available of this guy who had Kevin Spacey,
was touching his dick going back and forth with his girlfriend,
Bro.
They were laughing about it.
Okay.
And they're trying to make it seem like this is evidence that they were,
that he was scared and they,
Kevin Spacey was sexually abusing them.
They were like,
oh my God,
he's gay.
He's gay.
He's touching my dick.
He's gaze unzipping my pants.
He's gay.
This guy was texting his girlfriend while Kevin Spacey is Assholey so gay.
He's so gay.
I think he must be gay because I'm fucking him in his mouth now,
bro.
They sh they released all the text messages,
but they didn't release some of them.
And the mother said that she deleted a lot of them that are,
uh,
related to his frat boy,
like behavior.
What does that probably jokes about getting his Dick Sucked by Kevin Spacey.
Little Shit in there.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
No,
there's some deception going on,
I think.
I mean,
I'm not a,
obviously I'm not a lawyer,
but,
uh,
I think,
I think they're trying to make some money.
That's what I think is horse shit.
I don't think this 18 year old kids worried about this 800 year old man touching
his dick.
You flat line.
That guy just popped me in the face.
When you're 18,
you'll punch the fuck out of some 65 year old pervert cow man.
Unless he's a small fellow.
I don't know if he's,
I don't know.
No idea about his physical stature,
but if I was 18,
some guy was kept grabbing my dick,
I'd put them asleep.
Yeah.
To you go at night,
90% at 18.
You're like,
I'm going to fight you dude.
I'm like,
you're not going to fuck me man.
What does the messages start with the accuser texting?
Like he's hanging around me in the bar,
he's got my number and asked me to come out with him.
The girlfriend replies,
are you kidding?
And then sends to other messages saying what?
And then here it says,
sounds like he's hitting on you.
The man types I think he is.
And then he's grabbing my leg and expletive.
Oh my God,
you can't say cock and goes away to say I'm not gay adding.
But I think spacey is uh,
the accuser continued texting,
saying that he was being touched inappropriately like eight times later adding.
And then he invited me to his house.
Hey pro tip pro tip,
which was Julie [inaudible] your Dick.
You gotta tell him to stop looking at the job once.
Does he say the guy's girlfriend?
Stop.
What the expletive fuck his ass on this.
I saw this.
Have Fun.
Too much fun.
I was going to get to that.
She's just Christ.
He reached down my pants.
What the fuck is happening?
Have Fun but not too much fun,
if you know what I mean.
Jesus Christ.
He reached down my pants.
Help.
No,
this is Kevin Ducking spacey.
The bitch came even spelled,
she fucked with the auto tech stuff.
He's gay.
He's buying me another drink.
Oh my God,
Babe.
He's gay.
I think I want to hang.
This kid is gay.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Why are you,
do you choose your rights that he got autographs and a hell of a story.
Come on man.
Opportunistic.
Maybe.
Maybe it's not gay.
Maybe he's just a kid.
How do I do at time and doesn't understand how crazy this is.
Not a lot of people get sexually assaulted.
Have time to text.
Okay.
I'm just saying he's,
he's having fun playing around joining the fact that it was Kevin Spacey doing
to to them for sure,
but it doesn't sound to me in any way.
Like he was threatened.
He sounded like he let the guy touch him and maybe it should be accused of blue
bond.
Mr Spacey did space.
You get a nut.
Does it say that at the end?
But you think that he was flirting with them a little bit?
Clean them on,
keep Kevin Spacey around.
He thinks it's funny.
It's fucked up.
The whole story is fucked up.
If Kevin Spacey really did do it,
then it's fucked up that we're joking about it.
And if Kevin Spacey didn't do it,
then it's fucked up.
This guy's trying to set him up because he just wants to make money and he's
ruining Kevin Spacey's life.
But Kevin Spacey's laugh is already in trumpet spiral.
There's a lot of shit.
A lot of shit grabbing.
This was a nice lady and incident.
Yeah,
that was one.
One of many.
But if it's a different thing,
if you look at that story after you read those texts,
you,
oh,
this is a different thing.
This isn't like,
he's like trying to force some guy into a bathroom,
bludgeoned him and fuck them boys unconscious,
partied there,
partied out having a good time and he said they're buying is another drink.
The guy is hanging around.
Yes.
He's not being forced against his will.
There's no one that's holding them there.
You got your Dick grab once and he didn't want it.
You don't let it happen seven more times.
And everyone's like,
look,
the victim is crying for help.
Yeah.
Any text,
someone he just grabbed my Dick Dude.
Again,
it is,
this is what men have to really,
truly understand.
It is so much different when a guy like Kevin Spacey and I again,
I don't know what this guy looked like,
but I'm gonna assume it was me at 18 right?
A normal cool dude who does,
you know,
athletic stuff.
I'm strong at 18 and I,
I'm not worried about him raping me as what my point is where as a woman,
if a guy's doing that and you guys cornered you and fear there's fear,
you literally literally worried this guy could rape you.
I hope he's not that guy that would rate me the kind of guy,
right?
Because women don't know if you're the kind of guy that would rape them.
Cause look at Ted Bundy,
man.
He was a handsome guy and girls would just go with him because they thought like
,
oh he looks good,
he's fine now he's killing them,
right?
So girls legitimately have to worry about that work.
Guys don't.
So even this guy with Kevin Spacey,
if he didn't like what Kevin Spacey was doing,
there's no indication that he said it to him,
right?
So he's probably thinking,
we're going to party.
I'm touching this guy's Dick.
He ain't saying shit.
He's just texting his friends.
God,
tell your friends,
when I Fuck your mouth,
tell your friends I want to fuck your friends to bring those mothers under those
guys to bring the whole team.
I'll fuck all of them.
He's probably thinking he's going to have a good time because this guy's not
saying anything right.
Meanwhile,
this guy's texting is never does he say,
hey,
I told him to stop touching my dick and he won't leave me alone.
No,
it doesn't say that.
He invited me to his house.
We're ready to party.
I had to push him away from me.
I was kind of fucked him up,
but I guess he's drunk.
I'm coming to you baby,
cause I love you know that lol.
He's tricking me off in his mouth.
She says,
be careful,
have fun,
which is,
well,
you're out for the night.
I guess she even told him that being gay is okay.
She just said,
are you trying to tell me something being gay is okay.
That's when I responded,
I'm not k lol that I'll the first part for other kids not scared.
Okay.
This idea that he should get money because he was getting sexually assaulted.
No.
You're getting hit on and you're all at a,
an establishment that serves drugs.
The drug that reduces inhibition better than any drug,
alcohol,
and you're accepting this drug from this guy who has already touched your Dick
seven times.
Knowledging it.
By the way,
this isn't like a,
I didn't know what's happening because I didn't dictating lol.
Yeah,
joking about it.
My,
his Dick is in my ass.
Oh dear.
Oh,
what was happening?
Do you think that Kevin Spacey,
you should be able to sue him back counter suit for that,
for defamation of character just for being a bitch?
Yeah.
Just souffles being a bitch.
Like if there was a court of honor,
I'm sweater Babich like will you could a judge Santino um,
please welcome this case.
Uh,
Mr Spacey touched his boy's Dick over and over again and continue to buy him
drinks and the man never said no,
but he texted his girlfriend over and over again.
Then later on sued Mr Spacey for Sexual Assault.
Your thoughts,
young man,
you're guilty of being a bitch.
You must serve time as a biatch.
Okay.
Then the question is,
is there a real issue with him being 18 were like,
hey,
he's legal.
Maybe he's legal,
but maybe he's like bewildered.
Like he doesn't know what to do.
He's but maybe never been around a famous guy like Kevin Spacey before.
He doesn't know how to tell a guy to get off of them and doesn't have
experienced being around gay guys or maybe he's never had a guy tried to fuck
them.
Yeah.
But he doesn't want to get into the game.
The text all say that he's playing,
oh,
he's taught you meeting.
We're going to,
but maybe we're going to hang out with,
he's doing this game.
He's playing a game and material.
You're harassing the witness.
They can work at the bar.
Then what was he doing at the bar?
Uh,
sucking dicks.
Who's a gay bar?
18.
Is that a bar?
I think he worked there,
but there's what?
They lied to him and to until age 23 that was another part of the problem.
The kid lied and told seven Stacy who was older than he was bom bomb bomb.
The plot thickens.
So there's bars you can go into under 21 I know you can be in there.
I'm just saying like what was he doing just hanging out,
having fun or was he working like,
well he did say he's going to buy a strength.
That's what I meant.
Was he like a busboy and like he just kept walking by him and he kept grabbing
the stick every time they must find work there.
I'm looking at,
I don't see anything that we don't know.
They keep talking about this poor fella.
They didn't want to run into Kevin Spacey and,
but it was a financial opportunity and he had capitalized,
which can happen.
These,
are you going to go to jail?
No.
Fuck No.
These guys getting any money.
Yeah,
the kid hush money.
I get it.
How much does he want?
He'll get it all.
Set it that you got him drunk and then a sexually assaulted them at that bar is
what happened.
He worked there.
Is that what you said?
I worked there as a busboy.
Okay.
People,
people with wealth always get off.
Like,
what's her name?
Uh,
the USC people,
Lori Loughlin and it's fucked up,
man.
They get off the last season of house of cards.
Nobody gave a fuck about it.
There was a big billboard,
billboards,
and everybody was like,
oh,
okay.
There was a,
for your consideration.
What is her name again?
Uh,
uh,
Robin,
right.
Robin Wright.
She's amazing.
One of the best actresses I've,
we've ever had a lot.
She needed him to play off.
He was ultimate evil.
That was was turning her Maury.
Well they killed her boyfriend's boiler roller.
Yeah.
Borough row and in the moot.
By the way,
in the show,
he's doing a lot of gang shit like hand in hand.
Okay.
We'll show he's,
he does get,
he gets his cock,
sucked them in a library or some shit.
This guy's lot of crazy shit.
It's a crazy fucking which why I loved and it was amazing and you needed dirty,
crazy fuck like Kevin Spacey to pull that character off for sure.
Look,
the part of you knew,
he knew what it was to be a crazy fuck.
That's like part of how he pulled that roll off.
You bought it.
Okay.
This is not Ron Howard pretending to be bang and dudes and getting his dick
sucked and all that stuff.
Best roles.
He's playing a crazy guy.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
Yeah.
Always admit.
It's also why he's such an amazing artist,
but that doesn't give him a license to victimize.
All those people that you know when after that were sports.
It's not justifying,
but what I'm saying is it's amazing how someone who is fucked up like that can
produce,
you know,
like this kind of art where as an you,
like,
he makes a show,
right?
The show a big part of what it was.
Because you bought this guy as this crazy tormented,
twisted.
Absolutely.
I mean it was,
he was so,
he was so eloquent at it.
He has,
it was unbelievable.
It would just look,
it looked so natural,
so real.
That was probably because it was real.
Right?
100% I mean,
you know how many people in America,
you say for years and you're like,
Kevin Spacey's gay and that business has known about it and they go,
you're fucking out of your head.
You don't always gay.
But how many people in America where we go,
he's not,
he's not gay.
What are you nuts?
Fucking California.
Remember through everybody's good.
But that's the problem is because there's a perception perception.
And in the show,
him playing this character who's also art imitating life balancing on this world
of hiding a big secret.
It was just so close to home.
It was crazy.
Good show dude.
So good.
When she fell in love with that artist.
Oh,
so good with them in New York and there's pictures of them together and it's
like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
Crazy egg him naked in bed and some great examples and loft.
And so he needed them together after they kicked him out.
You're like,
what?
The damage is too strong.
When they were together.
It was amazing.
In the episode one that I watched the another watch,
everybody looks super nervous.
Everybody looked,
it looked like super.
It just looked.
What do you mean?
Just looked off the show,
looked off.
They like,
they knew Jesus Christ.
I just fired Kevin Spacey.
Never.
We're going to watch it on camera.
They're like,
so we'll just continue this game.
It was just weird.
Yeah.
I mean,
maybe it got better as time went on.
I didn't see it.
You know,
who I really liked too was the,
uh,
his assistant,
that guy that helped him out that would do anything for him that killed Rachel
Brosnahan.
Yeah.
What'd you put her in front of a train?
No,
no,
no.
That was him.
That was Kevin Spacey.
Kevin Spacey push the girl from the train and that was the guy went back and
killed the hooker.
Right.
That hooker went on to be the marvelous Mrs Maizel.
That's right.
Richard Branson.
Brosnahan that's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
She's dope.
She's great.
Very dope.
It's great in that Maizel show.
Yes.
That is a good fucking show.
You know Amazon's doing comedy specials now.
Are they or did Jim,
uh,
Jim Gaffigan.
Oh,
and Daniel did a Russell Peters and they're doing some other ones as well.
I'll do one.
I'll do one over there.
Amazon.
I'll do one with you like it.
Yeah,
I think it's cool.
Breaking the mold or the Netflix mold.
Everybody has Amazon prime,
dude.
Everybody does well now.
They own the whole foods.
When you go to whole foods,
you get a good discount on shit.
That's why I was like,
she was like,
do you have your app?
You scan your fucking APP.
Nice Gay Shelf,
a little bit of Turkey legs.
What do you want?
Take a little for you saw the bags of spinach once you check out at $2 off the
Amazon person.
Nice.
Yeah.
Um,
Amazon.
Yeah.
Amazon and the Amazon of the fucking world man content they're doing.
You buy things like,
I'm gonna wear weird company.
You buy stuff with one click,
you can watch TV shows.
They're making TV shows.
He could go buy your groceries.
When did they going to open up their town and was on town?
Where is it?
Where's it go?
Uh,
Buffalo.
They need
people in Buffalo.
Like please,
would you go to Amazon town?
Would you live there?
No.
It'd be a mess.
Jamie,
would you live in a lot of brown boxes?
Everywhere you look brown boxes,
we recycle everything.
They changed every,
the way.
Like grocery stores have to work now because they have that two hour delivery.
Like you have to have delivery at grocery store.
It's fucking some Pete.
I know,
but they do that with whole foods too,
right?
Does this whole foods deliver?
Yes.
We will.
Most grow most.
We will reach a point now when we don't go into grocery stores.
That's crazy.
They'll deliver.
Dude drives a kid.
No grocery stores delivered.
Do you remember your gross?
Never.
I've never heard of that delivered delivery.
No,
that didn't exist.
When did that start?
They do have the store to where you're walking in and just like,
it feels like you're stealing.
I haven't usually at this leave and they charge your account.
Oh my God.
Do you know New York?
They tested it out.
People just walk in and you have the APP in your phone so when you walk out it
registers what you have with you.
Whoa.
Fucking that's fucking insane.
Living in the future,
bro.
Doug,
you will net.
There'll be a point when we don't ever go to those things.
Someone just won't give.
You get an order every,
how long would it be before they can replicate food and all you have to do is
like put the bear ingredients and amino acids and shit and to some Vat and then
you print up anything you want.
Right up three D,
print a steak,
three d print an apple,
three d print a hungry for baked potato pizza.
Yeah,
for three d print it comes out.
but you know what,
what,
that's not going to taste good.
How do you know?
Because food has love in that shit.
People say that.
Oh,
you have these new cars.
Moons,
no sole.
Okay.
No,
but food is different.
Nutritions different.
You can never take,
you can't take,
you can't know.
It's says elements.
Just little things that they figured out how to fucking move around.
Wiggle.
I Dunno.
Something about there being so natural.
Perfect comes out with a nice like toast.
The crossed
your fucking computer.
Imagine
just the English muffin dude.
I don't think so.
There's no fucking way.
What did they nail it?
If they have like the perfect trochar call Saul a choice.
I think there's a touch to that,
but there is a shelter that Crawford but touch the human touch.
You needed that.
Like I don't feel like a robot might not be able to give a great massage.
Like you know they,
that the oils
in your hands are good when you eat with your hands just right.
A lot of the world is still eats with their fucking hands,
right?
Utensils take away already people.
But people,
your your hands have natural enzymes that kill a lot of bacteria or as Bro,
while I'm not wiping my ass on my hands anymore.
That's why in some countries it's a real insult to try to shake someone's hand
with your left hand.
Right.
Cause your booty hits your booty.
Booty and player.
Yeah,
Bro.
but do you know what?
I still think there's something about the touch of food when you feel someone
touches food,
it does something to enzymes.
A food.
I don't know about that fucking bullshit.
You learn from your astrologer.
Same Brow.
You believe in the tides,
Joe.
I got to think that.
You know there's something about the love of food that fucking robot him.
You know that if he's got a good heart.
Yeah.
He understands enzyme to come from your fingers.
They told that produced in your gut enzymes are produced.
The digestive things.
It's in your hands.
You make sure you,
yeah,
you do.
And you figure tips.
Yes.
What kind of enzymes it change.
It makes it that your food is a which read this.
Look it up.
Look at us.
I real look it up and was like,
you're talking about like a cast iron skillet,
like
through enzymes come off your fingers for something in your hands that changes
the chemical composition to food that changes the flavor profiles in your mouth
and it makes it so you don't get sick.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
Dirty hands are nice until you don't get sick,
dirty hands.
People have this what you say before you eat ass.
We fuck in.
Lift up your booty.
When do you eat ass?
And then have not yet.
What do you think?
How do you think their dirty hands,
they died.
They died out.
There were 30 years old.
Give it to me for a mouth and get outta here.
Get on in here.
That's coming up.
I typed in oils and hands change what's coming up.
It's like Mike Tyson weed
to make up ridiculous facts.
You look at again,
Jamie,
give me Sean being bro,
don't just Google it.
I'll let you pick the search.
What would you like me to search?
Search this.
Uh,
I got a peek.
All right.
Joe's gonna figure this out.
Yep.
Search,
search.
Search.
Uh,
cultures that eat with their hands don't get sick.
How about that?
It's just great
mind your manners.
Eat with your hands.
No.
Came from the same bowl as it's safe.
I feel like I didn't get a kit from around the world.
Look Dude,
there's gotta be,
there's some shit in people's hands that makes them not get sick when they eat.
What?
For years we ate without utensils.
Yeah,
but people got sick,
but not all the time.
Jamie got heat.
Helps that like cooking with heat.
Not everyone could cook with fire.
People ate a lot of raw chef for a long time.
You've got to find something on there and I'm looking.
You're killing me,
dude.
This is killing me.
I'm too high to look it up right now myself.
That's the bummer.
I don't even know how to do it,
man.
We're going to go to the bank.
Go to bank.
See what the fuck bing does.
Eating with
and
sick.
Yeah.
There's gotta be something.
Secrets of people who never get sick.
Let's see.
Let's just about sleeping,
sneezing,
vitamin C,
sleep it off.
Get a handle on stress.
Be a gym rat.
This is nothing.
You got nothing,
man.
Nothing coming up.
Got nothing son of a bitch.
Totally nothing here.
I don't know where you got in this room.
Hey,
just make it up for Joe.
Just lie when again,
when he comes back,
pull it and pull it.
We found so much stuff.
It's crazy to where have I heard this?
I've heard it somewhere.
Someone on the Internet is going to agree with me.
Some.
Some dude will find it.
The thing I had with bill Cosby or like he just filed today for an appeal
apparently.
Oh we did?
Yeah.
358 pages.
Hard fucking case to fight.
Huh?
How are we going to fight that dude?
Would you kill yourself?
I don't at him.
Tell him,
hey Jay,
Joe.
Jamie found a ton of fucking stuff.
Proven my shit.
Tons.
Fingertip QC 10 something like that.
Yeah.
No,
no,
absolutely not.
Couldn't find it
happens man.
Somebody told me have a dream and in that dream you're convincing.
I've heard it somewhere and then I thought,
wow,
that's amazing.
Cultures that eat with their hands.
There's enzymes in your hands.
They just,
they just don't want to change the forks and they'd say,
make up some story about Hindu gods.
I was in Central America.
Yes.
They told me they were eating shit rocked with the flesh.
They would use if you were bill caught.
We were saying that if you were bill Cosby,
would you just kill yourself?
Yes,
you would write.
I would just end it.
I don't know what you can do when you're that far down the hole.
Since he didn't file an appeal,
are you my,
so it's like,
here's a perfect example.
When we were talking about earlier with Louie,
think about Louis and now thinking about,
thinking about bill Cosby.
Totally different.
Right?
But people don't want you to say that cause they're both air quotes abusers.
One of them is a monster.
One of them was a guy who did some stupid shit.
Kinky Shit.
We're Chad.
He was into it.
He asked people,
they said yes,
he shouldn't have done it.
He feels bad that he did it.
But you can't.
How do you forgive?
Bill Cosby like to take that,
the idea that you're supposed to forgive Louie,
which I think yes,
and then I don't see a path for bill Cosby to be forgiven.
They don't see that path when you've ruined the lives of how many people?
50 plus when something's that heinous.
I just don't think,
I think I made a point to have you ruined their life.
You certainly certainly fuck them up.
Like if you wake up and you're with bill,
cause when you thought he was going to take care of you and your pants are down
by your ankles and you realize you're fucked you while your unconscious and he
drugged you,
that is going to fuck your head up.
Just going to change what you think about people that someone could just drug
you and treat you like meet your unconscious.
They're doing things to you when you're out cold.
We're saying,
what's our laws of forgiveness?
Well how do you forgive that?
First of all,
you can't because he'd Evers,
he doesn't admit it.
He never admits.
It never even gets to the door.
Right of like of acceptance,
of forgiveness,
of,
of doing his penance or if there is a penance of as anything you'd ever do ever.
He doesn't even get to the door.
Did she never gets it then would there be room for forgiveness?
It's a good question.
I think it would probably open up the door to more,
more lawsuits.
Sure.
I think he would,
they would come storming in like hail,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
But I think I know what you're saying is very smart.
It's saying like we're saying we were supposed to give someone like for someone
like Louie,
well what is the line of when you don't forgive,
right.
What's the line?
What is the how?
What's the number of what the line,
what's the atrocity like what is it that we go,
you can't forgive this person anymore.
What's the,
what's the line of compassion?
Like where do you,
where do you take line of compassion?
That's a good word.
That's what it is.
What is that ultimate where you go now you can no longer from this moment
forward,
forgive this human being and the problem is now here's where it gets slippery.
If you decide you're going to be the guy who says,
I'm going to kill this guy,
someone that actually cures him.
Yeah.
If you decide,
if you live in a company,
look with this,
what we're essentially doing,
we're just doing it slow at putting them in a cage.
Right?
Right.
But if you were going to really decide,
hey,
we're going to,
we're going to remove this guy from the population.
I can't trust him with my kids.
We live in a primitive society.
Okay.
We live in some some village type society thousands of years ago.
Right.
That's what we all did.
What would we do when someone was like that?
While we'd probably try to figure out a way to get rid of them.
Yeah,
you kill him.
You don't have to kill him.
Yeah,
you'd have to,
but you'd have to figure out what are the laws that allow someone to kill
somebody.
Because you can't just let people kill people because he let people kill people.
Then you just come up with excuses to kill people.
Right?
And this is what people have done throughout history,
whether it's the mon goals,
the Romans,
I mean,
just go throughout history.
People have people fucking killed people because they could kill people.
So when do you,
what,
what is the moral distinction that you have to make where someone is,
they have done irreparable harm,
but that changes over time,
right?
Right.
That and that continually changes.
That's,
that's my point is like that will never stop changing from,
from,
from decade to decade,
from era to era.
What we find deplorable now will not be deplorable later.
And that see,
with so many aspects of our culture,
yes.
Literature,
movies,
the way we restrict what so,
so what we're saying is,
is there ever align,
is there ever a lun?
Does it ever exist?
Does that idea of like this is the cutoff,
does that really exist?
Because it's constantly moving.
It's constantly changing.
You know,
I,
I've said it a million times.
I've never said what Louie did was okay.
I think he has his,
his issues.
I don't think anybody has,
but I also think everybody needs to investigate what happened and find out
what's going to talk about what,
yes,
I'm sure.
Let him talk about it.
Find out what the social psychology of what he was going through.
Yeah.
But disturbed.
But what I think is happening too is that a lot of women feel like when these
guys that are abusers get taken out,
that it made it so that it was better for women and so that if they come back
things to go back the way they were,
this is a real,
that's a real thought,
you know?
Yes.
But we must have conversation.
Yeah.
We don't have conversation then we're fucked.
I mean that's a real thought with imagine being a guy like Harvey Weinstein who
was doing this for so long,
get away with all this fucked up shit for so long.
Supported,
supported by them,
support it,
support.
I mean,
he had a clause in his contract detailing what would happen for the first case
of a sexual harassment.
Second case support days in the contract.
So why don't,
why are there,
fuck,
why are they,
why,
why aren't the people that support him up?
Hey cito um,
I'd love you to join my podcast network.
I'm thinking about promoting you then.
I just think you're a great guy.
You're a funny guy.
You're a talented guy up dot.
Thank you.
Might be a raper.
So what I want to put is the first rape.
Uh,
I'm going to charge you this much second.
What the fuck a fuck.
Imagine the first sexual harassment is,
I've got a figure and then the second one lawsuit has a another figure us a
double the finger.
They're like three strikes you're out,
but it's not something he can afford.
It's like two 5,500 grand.
He's like a billionaire.
He's Harvey wines.
He goes fine.
He made pope fixed and he's like,
Hey,
I'll clear it up,
tear it up.
He's eating food while their talk and it's fucking crumbs all down his face off.
He's jerking off while they're talking to glutton,
the glutton,
a filthy fat fucking glutton.
You can't make a better case for a glutton.
And that guy,
he's a metaphor for the business by the way.
All consuming taking right.
And this looks totally,
yeah,
he,
he would,
he would ruin what's beautiful.
Right.
Take what's beautiful.
Pretty same mouth.
This fat gut rested on their forehead.
He fucked.
He ruined pretty things.
Yeah,
he's far pretty things.
Horrible.
Fuck that guy.
But it's interesting because that is a villain in a movie.
He's like a,
he's a villain in a movie.
Yes.
He's like a,
like a bad Dick Tracy character.
You're not,
not more modern.
He's a villain.
He's a villain more in a fucking Harvey Weinstein movies.
What he is,
Oh yeah,
someone will make that film.
He's a villain and no,
but he's a villain in a Quentin Tarantino movie.
Right.
If there was a guy who was doing dark shit and then one of the girls winds up
leading like a,
some kick ass female character,
one's up shooting them and killing them.
Like I said,
Hannah,
what the fuck's her name?
Oh,
um,
the woman who's in kill Bill.
Um,
not Uma Thurman,
but the Daryl,
Daryl Hannah,
like Daryl Hannah,
Daryl.
Hannah winds up killing him tight,
like hit him.
Kills Him with a brick.
Oh.
Plus his fucking head open like Patricia Arquette
when she killed Tony Soprano.
Yes.
Member.
Right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She was doe.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Shit.
That was perfect.
He was the perfect character.
That Tony Soprano character that she killed when James Gandolfini in true
romance.
When was it Patricia Arquette sounds like.
Yeah,
that's our cat was just to our cats.
Well,
no.
What's the other art cat is to our cats.
I said,
no,
for sure.
I,
again,
it was Patricia,
Patricia,
but there's none of that as a girl.
There's another girl there.
Yeah.
Am I tripping?
No,
no,
no.
There is,
I'm sorry.
Don't you shake your head,
bitch.
She's dead.
Oh,
Shit.
Which one,
Bro?
You better not be wrongs.
That's even worse.
It's bad if you're missing.
She's not dead.
Jamie,
Rosanna.
Arquette.
Yes.
Oh,
Shit.
She's been in a gang of movies too.
She was in pulp fiction.
Yes.
Rosanna Arquette was in pulp fiction.
She was,
uh,
wasn't she one of the chick she was a part of,
like when a girl over any Marino had to overdose,
overdose,
a helper.
That was her.
They had to help her.
Yeah.
That was her,
that she was helping him with Herman.
She was to go the head shit,
all of her face,
as he said did.
She goes,
your wife,
I should all over.
He goes,
who's the girl with the all over her face?
And he goes,
that's my wife.
And he's like,
Oh shit.
Will they like piercings or something?
Yeah,
she had piercings,
right?
Wasn't that it right?
He goes,
he goes,
who is it?
He goes,
how's the chick?
Was Shit all over her face.
And he goes,
that's my fucking wife,
man.
Him Movie,
What a fucking movie.
Anyway,
um,
easily one of the best films ever.
Amazing.
Always amazing movie.
But Patricia Arquette and true romance,
right when she killed James Gandolfini,
that's she's killing the glutton.
Killing the big disgusting you asshole man.
Big asshole.
Shitty man doesn't give a fuck about women and he's going to kill her.
She fucking,
ah,
she fucking kills him.
And you're like,
yes.
Got Blood coming down her face.
It's crazy.
Shit is dope.
That's a great fucking seen.
Crazy.
That is that scene.
By the way,
that publication scene,
the revive the heart revival scene's just awesome nuts.
Awesome.
So many scenes in that movie.
Like what?
I remember I saw that movie when I first moved to Hollywood.
It was like 1994 I think.
I first moved here and I was watching that movie.
I was like,
is this what it's like out here?
They're saying as new movie is awesome.
He said it's,
he said it's his best movies made since then and I've heard the reviews are
awesome and they're telling the audiences to not spoil it for the rest of the
people that are going to see is that once upon a time in Hollywood comes out in
like a month thread.
Pitt,
who else?
Uh,
Brad Pitt,
Leo Dicaprio and Margot Robbie.
Yup.
They redid a bunch of Hollywood.
May Look at the 70s that you can still see some of it on sunset if you haven't
realized why some of it's been repainted and weird way as it was because of
those scenes they were shooting.
So I picked,
I was going,
you know Ben Harper,
the musician?
Yes.
Um,
couldn't name a song,
but I know who he is.
Yeah.
He's a dope dude.
Hit Him and I were going to dinner at Muse,
Musso and Frank's,
and he likes that place.
I said,
that's what it is.
Amazing.
He goes,
meet me a moose on,
frankly,
I love Busan Franks.
And I show up there.
I'm like,
dude,
what the fuck is going on?
Sure enough,
they're shooting.
Half the movie takes place in there.
Right there,
right there,
because it still looks like that.
So there was like the best place for them to do it.
It's like,
that's really,
go hang out,
eat dinner while they're filming a movie right after they were until say just
finish it.
Just,
Oh wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It was fucking,
I mean they were like,
I w I,
I told the guy,
I go,
something's gotta be going on.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
you guys are okay.
But you know self saying,
Nah,
Nah.
You know what?
I called it out.
I act like I've been here before.
Jesus students already six 10 meeting.
They're actually right there in the trailer from the trailer.
Amazing.
That's it.
No.
Yeah,
that is what's on frankly,
that's Muslim.
Frank's yeah,
I played is amazing.
It's super hero.
Dog School feels it feel,
you know what if fucking feels like he's been there a hundred years or for her
birthday.
Yeah,
I love Musso Frank's place.
They should go.
That should be a place where you should go to Frank's and we could do that
before a show.
You know,
I would love that.
I have dinner gentlemen,
like adults have a scratch with a big piece.
I'm a scotch with some ice and some sticks out in my decade.
We go give me a check given the Cha for like,
Mick Jagger likes to go there all the time too.
With Jagger.
I hope we do.
Really does he like to go there?
They went there before they had their concert on Hollywood boulevard,
like
buck.
That motherfucker can still dance.
Oh,
he had a heart attack,
had open heart surgery or whatever you have kit and he was on stage like a month
later struck this shit.
Just do it.
That just means the universe makes,
wants him to live.
He's a beast.
He lived,
he works out every day.
Multiple Times.
Does he?
Yeah.
He uh,
does dancing and yoga and lifts,
weights,
all kinds of shit.
There was a period where he never,
he never worked at once.
There was a period when it was on the road and there's no way on imagine back on
stage after 11 weeks after having surgery.
Heart Surgery.
Fucking unreal.
Sounds like me,
bro.
75 years sounds like me,
I know,
bro.
If I'm getting heart surgery,
I'm done.
That's it.
Challenging.
Yeah.
I'm walking,
I'm walking our snuck off someone's Dick Enough,
take a bunch of water from target or whatever the fuck.
Where was the water from?
Water Bitch.
He works out three hours a day.
Three hours.
It's what their guitars to the doctor said they've never operated on an athlete
at 75 before.
So they had a really good laugh about that.
And I said,
he's still fit.
He works out three hours a day.
How many,
how old is he now?
75 if you keep going,
you didn't pause,
but if you slow down and stop,
your shit will break.
Joe Rogan.
That's the message of the dailies.
Great fucking quote.
We're going to wrap this up.
People on the road.
Cheeto Santina will be meet with me this weekend.
Friday and y'all mother fucking Saturday,
Friday at the Borgata in Atlantic city,
two shows,
and then Saturday and Baltimore.
I don't know where we are.
Good to go to Joe rogan.com some big ass place with the great and powerful Tony
Hinchcliffe.
Um,
the whiskey ginger podcast is available everywhere,
everywhere,
everywhere.
All right?
He'd beautiful baby.
I love you.
Love you,
love you.
Hey Maddie.
Fun Times is always shout out to young Jamie hollow.